HUMAN SERVICES WE HAVE ELEVEN
BILLS ON THE CALENDAR TODAY.
THE FOLLOWING THREE BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT SB.
TWO NINETEEN SB.
THREE SIX FIVE AN SP
[inaudible]
FOUR FOUR ZERO WE HAVE
AND BUT BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
[inaudible]
PRODUCT.
HERE HURTADO HERE STONE.
STONE HERE THE BILL.
WELL HERE JACKSON PAN WIENER.
PRESIDENT WINNER HERE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SWITCH TO THE SECTOR YEAH OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RIGHT SB THREE NINETEEN WILK THE
MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH RECOMMENDS
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SB THREE SIXTY FIVE DURAZO THE
RECOMMEND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND SB FOUR FORTY PAN THE
RECOMMENDED OR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS OF CONSENT
CALENDAR.
RICARDO.
RICARDO I STEM.
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON PAN WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THAT HAS FOUR BOOKS NOW.
THIS.
WAS A REAL.
OUR FOUR ZERO THE BILL ARE THE
BILLS ARE OUT ON CONSENT.
WITH.
THAT WE CAN HELP.
AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND HOLD IT
OPEN.
SO WE HAVE.
WHICH WHICH IS THE THIRTY SIX
MITCHELL.
WE HAVE A SENATOR MITCHELL -- IT
WILL BE PRESENT TEEN.
SB. 231-321-3321 [inaudible]
WELCOME THANK.
FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
HELPFUL -- ANALYSIS HELPFUL IN
THAT IT GIVES A GREAT KIND OF
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE -- CAL
WORKS AND HOW THE CHILD CARE CAL
WORK STAGES ONE TWO AND THREE
SYSTEM CAME INTO BEING PEOPLE
OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE EARLY CAN EDUCATION SYSTEM
IS BROKEN AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
IT'S NOT HIS CHILDREN.
RECEIVE CARE IN THAT SYSTEM
EVERY DAY BY THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANALYSIS -- IT PAINTS THE FULL
PICTURE OF HOW WE GOT TO THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
MEMBERS SB THREE TWENTY ONE
STREAMLINED STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
ELIGIBILITY RULES SO THAT ALL
COUNT WORK FAMILIES ARE FOR THE
SAME BENEFITS A STABLE RELIABLE
AND CONSISTENT SHOCK HERE
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE.
THEIR FAMILY SUCCESS THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE INTER AGENCY TASK FORCE
ON CAL WORKS CHILDCARE A DIVERSE
WORK GROUP OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS WHO LABOR
FOR OVER A YEAR.
RESULTED IN THE POLICY THAT IS
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
IT'S ALSO A PRIMARY OF PRIORITY
AT THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS.
SB THREE SB THREE TWO ONE BILLS
ON THE POSITIVE IMPACT THE
RECENT POLICY REFORMS.
INCLUDING THE REPEAL THE MAXIM
FAMILY GRANT RULE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ADOPTING THE TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE AND ALL DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CHILDCARE SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND LIFTING CAL
WORKS CASH GRANTS ABOVE THE
POVERTY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN WHEN CALIFORNIA ENACTED
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IT MADE A
PROMISE TO FAMILIES THAT
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO KEEP THEIR CHILDREN
SAFE AND LEARNING AS PARENTS
GAIN THE SKILLS THEY NEED IT.
SAVE A LIFE THEIR FAMILIES AND
RE INTO THE WORK FORCE.
IN THE TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
AND I'VE BEEN HERE FOR EVERYONE
OF THEM LOWER WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT ON INTERRUPTED AND
CONSISTENT CHILDCARE IS PRE
REQUISITE FOR FAMILY ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
STABLE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
GIVES FAMILIES MORE OPTIONS TO
IMPROVE THEIR FUTURE AND GIVES
CHILDREN A STRONG START.
CLOSING GAPS BEFORE INEQUITIES
WIDEN PARTICULARLY FOR LOW
INCOME CHILDREN AND CHILDREN OF
COLOR.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS NINE EMAIL
FOSSE APPARENT LEADER FROM
PARENTS VOICES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND PATTY PUT OVER WHO IS HERE
WITH TECHNICAL EXPERTISE FROM
THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER A
MEMBER OF OUR SPONSOR COALITION
FOR TRUNKS FOR A STRONGER
CALIFORNIA I ASKED FOR AND I
ABOUT.
HELLO AND AN INTRODUCED MYSELF
FIRST -- MY NAME IS NOT ENOUGH I
SEE I AM ORIGINALLY FROM ALGERIA.
AND I AM A MEMBER OF PENS VOICES
IN SAN FRANCISCO -- I HAD MAY
BASHES DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY AND
MAY MUST TO CITY IN
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS AND
MANAGEMENT FOR MAY AND MAY HOME
COUNTRY.
I GETS MADE -- IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN BUT UNFORTUNATELY MAY I
MAY MARRIAGE DIDN'T GET TWELFTH
SO -- DIDN'T GO WELL SO -- THEY
DECIDED THEY DECIDED TO GET
DIVORCED -- IT WASN'T THAT EASY
SO WE MOVED TO SAN FRANCISCO.
BECAUSE IT'S EASIER FOR ME TO BE
IN A BIG CITY WHERE THEY JUST
TRANSPORTATION AND AND AND THEY
COULD RESOURCES FOR MEN MAKE ITS
MAKE IS AT THE TIME THERE WERE
THREE AND FOUR THE FIRST THING
THAT THEY WANTED TO ADD.
IT WAS THINKING OF IS JUST TO GO
TO CAR WORKS TO GET SOME HELP
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HOT THEY HAD
TO MY SON AT TWENTY FOUR WEEKS --
AND HE WAS STUDYING WITH SOME
HEALTH ISSUES SO -- I WANTED --
TO A WANTS TO CALL WORKS TO ASK
FOR HELP IT WAS A REALLY
DIFFICULT TO APPLY FOR CON LOOKS.
BUT I I WAS LUCKY TO GET LIKE
SOME BENEFITS SO WE GET THE CASH
EIGHT HYUNDAI GETS A CONFERENCE --
FOR EACH MONTH.
WHICH HELPED A LOT BUT IT'S
STILL THE THE SUBTLE DIDN'T GO
AWAY.
ADD BOTH KIDS WERE WITH ME ALL
THE TIME.
I REMEMBER THAT THEY WAS MAKING
LIKE ALMOST TWENTY CALLS.
A DAY.
TRYING TO FIND HOUSING.
AND ALSO TRYING TO FIND LIKE --
THE EMPLOYMENT OR SIZE CARE FOR
THE KIDS -- BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THE LOOKS HAVEN'T
MENTIONED ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
HAVE LIKE YOU KNOW PROVIDING
WITH CHILD CARE OR SUPPORT FOR
KIDS.
SO I I WANT ANOTHER ORGANIZATION
AND THEY ASKED FOR YOU KNOW WAIT
EXPLAINED THE SITUATION AND THEY
I SAID YOU KNOW WE HAVE I HAVE
TWO KIDS AND AND YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO FIND LIKE A JOB OR
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL OR YOU KNOW.
LAKE MAKING MY LIFE A LITTLE BIT
A LITTLE BIT LIKE BETTER.
SO THE THEY TOLD ME NO THE ONLY
OPTION THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
WITH THE IT'S JUST TO PUT YOUR
KIDS ON THE WAITING LIST.
WHICH IS FOR US OF THREE AT SAN
FRANCISCO.
THREE THEY PUT MAKE KIDS ON THE
WAITING LIST.
AND IT WAS LUCKY TO THEY CALLED
ME FOR LIKE ABOUT YOU KNOW THREE
OR FOUR MAYBE FOUR OR FIVE WEEKS
THEY CALLED ME AND THEY THEY
SAID YOUR KIDS YOU KNOW OF THAT
ARE LIKE YOU ELIGIBLE TO FOR
CHILD CARE.
SO -- I NOW IS THE SOUTHERN NO
WE FIND A PROVIDER FOR THEM AND
THEY STARTED YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
GOING TO PRESCHOOL.
THE DAYCARE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT DIDN'T GO
THAT WELL BECAUSE MAKE KITS
WHERE YOU KNOW OVER WELL AND
THEY WERE YOU KNOW.
THEY HAVE YOU KNOW THE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA AND THEY ALSO
A TEST MY STRESS ON THEM BECAUSE
THEY WILL ALWAYS STRESSED AND
YOU KNOW TRY TO DO EVERYTHING AT
ONCE -- SO THEY WERE ALL
STRESSED AND OVERWHELMED SO WE
HAVE TO CHANGE THE CHILD CARE
AGAIN BECAUSE IT IT WAS REALLY A
YOU KNOW IT WAS LITERALLY HOW.
AND THEN -- I DECIDED TO YOU
KNOW.
RIGHT WELL WHEN THEY FOUND
ANOTHER CHILD CARE FOR THE MEALS
ALMOST THE SAME THING THEY THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO SETTLE DOWN AND
YOU KNOW FOCUS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
MY SITUATION I DON'T HAVE
HOUSING AT THE TIME EIGHT EVEN
KNOW WE WERE JUST LIVING WITH ME.
A FRIEND OF MINE -- WITH TWO
KIDS IN IN THE STUDIO SO -- I
WILL STRUGGLING YOU KNOW AND
MOST OF THE TIME THEY DON'T HAVE
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH FOOD FOR
MAY YOU KNOW FOR MYSELF.
AND FOR MAY BOTH KIDS.
I THEY GIVE US LIKE THEY GIVE US
CUT FRESHMAN'S USUALLY LIKE IT
STAYS FOR ABOUT THREE WEEKS.
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO WITH THE REST LIKE
THIS.
THE REST OF THE THE TIME.
I USE LIKE WAS THE MOST OF THE
TIME IS A USE THE CASH.
YOU KNOW TO BUY FOOD.
AND THEN AFTER THAT AM TWENTY
FOUND THAT YOU KNOW THAT I
DECIDED THAT YOU KNOW THE THE
DAYCARE SO I'M NOT GOING TO WORK
THAT ONE FOR MY KIDS SO WE
DECIDED TO GO TO SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND THEN A IN OLD AND NEW THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY STARTED
SCHOOL AND YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE IN GOOD IN GOOD HANDS
THEY HAVE MARINO.
THEY HAVE MORE KNOWLEDGE WITH
THIS KIND OF YOU KNOW KIDS --
THEY STAYED THERE AND THEY WERE
STABLE I DECIDED TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL I SAY DECIDED YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S JUST FOR A MORE
CONVENIENT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
THEN GO TO WORK BECAUSE EIGHT
EIGHT JUST.
I HAVE FELT THAT WAY I STARTED
SCHOOL AND THEN -- THEY HAD A
FRIEND OF MINE ALSO YOU KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW -- WAS CALLED THAT
COME OAK THEY HAVEN'T MENTIONED
ANYTHING ABOUT GOING TO WORK OR
GIVING ME LIKE ALL THE OPTIONS
FOR MACHINE ANYTHING ABOUT CHILD
CARE SO.
I DECIDED A I WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL AND THEN WENT TO A FRIEND
OF MINE FROM CITY COLLEGE SHE
SAID YOU KNOW.
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING TO GO TO
WORK BECAUSE SHE SHE SAW ME THAT
BECAUSE THE STRUGGLE WITH MONEY
I HAVE LIKE YOU KNOW?
I HAVE A LITTLE MONEY AND NO ONE
FROM MOST OF THE TIME THEY DON'T
HAVE YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE
FOOD.
AND THAT SHE SAID YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A GOOD OPTION TO GO ON
WALKS LIKE A DORK STUDYING AND
HOW GOING TO DO WITH THE KIDS IN
CASE THEY GET SICK.
SOMETHING HAPPEN -- SHE SAID NO
JUST GO FOR IT AND YOU KNOW GIVE
IT A TRY AND SEE HOW WITH A HOW
IS GOING TO WORK SO WE WANT. TO
WORK.
AND THEN FOR THE FIRST.
YOU KNOW FOR THE FIRST MONTH
SECOND MONTH HE WAS KIND OF
SCARED THEY WASN'T ABLE.
TO FOCUS AND BUT AND THEN AFTER
THAT HE FELT COMFORTABLE AND HE
STARTED WORKING AND MAY INCOME
INCREASED WHICH IS GOOD.
AND THEN THEY FELT COMFORTABLE.
AND THEN THAT'S ONE TRIED TO
THEY CALLED ME AND THEY SAID YOU
KNOW THE HOUSE NOW WE HAVE AN
OPTION TO HAVE TRIED GIVE FOUR
LIKE FULL.
FULL TIME CHILD CARE FOR KIDS
FOR THE YOU KNOW FOR THE WHOLE
YEAR.
AND IT WAS LIKE SHOCKED THEY
SAID LIKE YOU KNOW WAIT I WAS
HOPING TO TELL ME THAT LIKE
SINCE THE BEGINNING BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN THEY NEED IT THE
MOST.
NOW WE HAVE SO MANY ALL THE
OPTIONS MAKE ITSELF GROWN THERE
ARE THEY CUT THE TIME THEY WERE --
FIVE AND SIX I WAS DISAPPOINTED
BECAUSE THEY WAS HELPING TO HELP
ME TO YOU KNOW TO TO PROVIDE ME
WITH THE RESOURCES.
AND HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE IF I HAD ALL
THIS YOU KNOW THIS OPPORTUNITIES
TO KNOW WHAT'S WHAT WHAT MY
OPTIONS WHERE.
A WAS LIKE AT LEAST A SAVE THOSE
TWO YEARS THEY FINISHED MAY
SCHOOL BAY NOW A FINISHED MY
SCHOOLING AND THEY STARTED
WORKING FULL TIME BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I HAD NO IDEA
BOOKS LIKE.
ALL THE OPTIONS THAT THEY YOU
KNOW THAT THE PROGRAM --
SUPPOSED TO YOU KNOW TO OFFER
THE CLIENTS SO A I STRUGGLED FOR
VOTE ALL THIS TIME.
WITH MAY AND MAY TWO KIDS SAID
THEY ARE THEY FEEL NOW THAT THEY
ALL THIS YOU KNOW.
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES THEY WERE
STRUGGLING WITH AN ALL OVER YOU
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN IN THEIR
LIVES AND MY LIFE YOU JUST
BECAUSE OF THE YOU KNOW THE LUCK
OF THE THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY RESOURCES
AND ANY HELP FROM COLOR.
AND NOW TODAY I AM HERE I WANTED
TO SHARE MY STORY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T.
AYE AYE I AM HOPING THAT LIKE
ALL THAT OUR PARENTS.
IN MAY CASE.
THEY THEN I CAN AS EXPERIENCE
THE SAME WHAT I AM EXPERT YOU
WANT TO EXPERIENCE BEFORE I
WASTED MY TIME MANY YOU KNOW WAY.
I WAS UNDER PRESSURE AND AND A
LOT OF STRESS WITH TWO LITTLE
KIDS.
AND I MEAN I AM HOPING. TO YOU
KNOW. TO AVOID ALL THIS STRUGGLE
FOR ALL THE PARENTS AND ALL THE
KIDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M PATTI PRINT UBER FROM
THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER I JUST
WANT TO THINK IS FUSSY AND OF
COURSE SENATOR MITCHELL FOR HER.
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL AND
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE -- BUT I I KNOW THAT THIS
OF COMMITTEES ALREADY VERY
SUPPORTIVE WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ARE
WE WILL NOT OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND SO PLEASE COME UP TO THE
STUDY MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR
NAME.
WHAT ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND YOUR POSITION?
OF SUPPORT.
KEVIN KEVIN AS THEN COLUSA
CALIFORNIA WILL PROVIDE CERTAIN
ADDITION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE CAN SEE QUESTIONS ON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HI CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON WITH
YOU W. AFFECTS ME WE ARE SPONSOR
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RENDON TO IT ON BEHALF OF CAN
DANGLE A LARGE NONPROFIT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND REALLY
CARE PROVIDER IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA IN SUPPORT.
HIGH TEMPERATURES.
TRIAL THREE SIXTY LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN IT'S GO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
HI ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI JENNIFER CRAPPIE WITH PARENT
VOICES CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS
THE STATE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DESPERATE LOW WESTERNS AND ALLOW
PARTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ONE WITH
GRACE AND TELL POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IN THE WATER WITH CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO COME
FORWARD.
ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE BILL.
THE OKAY [inaudible]
GREAT.
CENTER WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND OUT.
PRESS PRECIADO XIN FOR PARENTS
VOICES CHAPTER MEMBER FOR A
WILLINGNESS HER WILLINGNESS TO
COME FORWARD AND SHARE HER OWN
STORY AGAIN THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS BILL STREAMLINING AND
CREATING GREATER EFFICIENCIES
WE'VE DONE THIS WOK FOR STATES
TO WIN THREE CHILD CARE WE THINK.
STAGE ONE CHILD CARE WERE.
OF FAMILIES ARE IT MOST IN FLUX
TO CREATE THE STABILITY OF
TWELVE MONTHS CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY IS PROBABLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO ON BEHALF OF
STREAMLINING THE PROGRAM ON
BEHALF OF OF THE LIVES OF THE
FAMILY AND THE FAMILIES OF THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE RECEIVING THE
CHAPTER SERVICES.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATE MITCHELL I I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENTED FIFTH.
WITH ANYBODY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT -- SECURITY MIGHT OUT
CALDERON.
CA.GOV.
I RETURNED A AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN NIGHT CAN I AND
WIENER.
WIENER AYE. SIX AND THE MOTION
ON THAT BILL WAS DUE PASSED TO
EDUCATION.
THE BILL IS OUT VERY MUCH.
DO PASSED THE SENATE.
SO UP NEXT BEST CENTER COMING AT
ALL -- SB.
TWO NINE EIGHT WELCOME SENATOR
COMING AT ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB.
TO NINETY EIGHT WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH SPECIFIC TARGETS THE
END DEEP CHILD POVERTY IN FOUR
YEARS AND REDUCE TRY CHILD
POVERTY BY 50% BY TWENTY THIRTY
NINE AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
ADJUSTING THAT NUMBER -- DOWN.
WHICH WILL PUT US ON A PATH TO
REDUCING CHILD POVERTY IN OUR
STATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE IN THE NATION.
RECENT COMPREHENSIVE STUDIES
SUCH AS THE REPORT BY THE
LIFTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY TASK FORCE AND
THE NATIONAL
STATE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE -- THIS BILL
IS IS CRUCIAL THEIR OF
ESSENTIALLY BEEN TWO REASONS
THAT THE STATE IS NOT MADE.
PROGRESS IN PAST YEARS IT
ACTUALLY REDUCING.
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN POVERTY IN THE FORD
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CHILDREN.
IN DEEP POVERTY IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURES DONE A TERRIFIC JOB
IN MAINTAINING THE SAFETY NET
AND FIGHTING TO EXPAND IT.
BUT THE NUMBER AND PERCENTAGE OF
CHILDREN IN POVERTY HAS GONE UP
AND DOWN A BIT WITH THE ECONOMY
BUT NEVER REALLY BEEN REDUCED
THEIR TWO REASONS FOR THAT.
THE FIRST IS THERE IS NOT BEEN A
COMPREHENSIVE EVIDENCE BASED
PLAN DATABASE PLAN. TO DID
PROVIDE A ROAD MAP. TO ELIMINATE
THE CHILD POVERTY IN REDUCE
OVERALL CHILD POVERTY BY AT
LEAST 50%.
THAT IS NOW THEN PROVIDED A BY
THE TASK FORCE AND THE PRIORITY
BILLS OF ALL BEEN INTRODUCED AS
LEGISLATION.
BUT THE SECOND CRITICAL POINT IS
THERE NEEDS TO BE A STATED STATE
GOAL.
AND THEN REGULAR MEASUREMENTS
THE TRACK THE PROGRESS TOWARDS
MEETING THE CALL.
SO THAT THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE JUDGMENTS
ABOUT WHAT ELSE PERHAPS NEEDS TO
BE DONE WHAT CHANGES NEED TO BE
MADE IN ORDER TO MEET THAT GOAL.
SO THE CRITICAL PIECE IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY REDUCING CHILD AND
FAMILY POVERTY IN THE STATE.
IS NOT JUST IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS
BUT THE PASSAGE.
OF SB TO NINETY EIGHT SO THAT
THERE ARE REGULAR MEASUREMENTS
SO THAT YOU CAN TRACK PROGRESS
TOWARDS THE GOAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOME TO TARA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MAHDI THE LUNAR I'M
APPARENTLY TO REPRESENTING CAN'T
VOICES -- WHEN WE IS FAMILIES
UTILIZE SOCIAL SERVICES THE
STATE REQUIRES ACCOUNTABILITY
FROM US FOR ME -- I MYSELF IN WE
AS PARENTS FILL UP HUNDREDS OF
FORMS COPIES OF OUR DOCUMENTS --
WE HAVE TO CHECK IF THERE'S ANY
CHANGES WE HAVE TO PROVIDE ALL
INFORMATION -- IF THE COSTLY
PROVE THAT WE ARE STILL ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
I WAS EVEN PERSONALLY --
PERSONALLY FINGERPRINTED WHEN I
APPLIED FOR CAL WORKS TWO YEARS
AGO SO YOU HAD TO GIVE UP MY OWN
FINGERPRINT.
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTABLE TO
PARENTS LIKE ME WHO ARE WORKING
HARD TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
WE LIKE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
SAYS THAT WERE NO LONGER WILLING
TO MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO.
THAT IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WE SHOULD HAVE TO BE THE HIGHEST
RATED HIGHEST RATE OF CHILD
POVERTY IN THE NATION.
TO THIS BILL PROVIDES A COPY OF
ITS APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
POVERTY FOR FAR TOO LONG WE HAVE
FUND SOME PROGRAMS AT THE
EXPENSE OF OTHERS WHEN IN
REALITY.
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN
EXTREME POVERTY NEED ALL OF IT.
ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS. TO BUG
BECAME THE CAPITOL ONE DAY TOTAL
LESSER EVERY MONTH THAT THEY
BUDGET THEIR FAMILY INCOME DOWN
TO THE LAST DROP OF MILK IN THE
FRIDGE.
THIS IS THE IMPACT OF LIVING
ANTI POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
ASK YOU DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH A
DROP OF OIL COSTS.
WELL MY FRIEND YOU BUT DOES.
FAR TOO LONG FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN BEEN IN BY VISIBLE LIKE
MINES IN THE STATE IN OUR
SOCIETY WHAT PEOPLE THINK OF
POVERTY THEY THINK OF A PICTURE
OF A DAHLE AND USUALLY NOT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
I'M A SOLE PARENT.
IN A SOLO PARENT HOUSEHOLD WITH
EXTREME PRICES IN HOUSING AND
CHILD CARE MY FAMILY IS ONE OF
THE FAMILIES THIS CHIP
LEGISLATION COVERS.
BEAN INVISIBLE OF SOCIETY ALSO
FURTHER PLACES SHAME ACOSTA
SEROTYPES UPON CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES LET'S OPEN THE BLINDS
AND SHINE THE LIGHT AND VOTE HI
AND PASSED SB TWO EIGHT ON THREE
THREE TWO THREE TWO NINE EIGHT
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY TO GET OUT
THE LOWEST POVERTY RATE.
IN THE NATION IS TO TAKE ACTION
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT TWO DAYS
FAMILIES SO WE CAN ANTI POVERTY
TOMORROW THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO MY STORY.
THANK YOU WILL NOT OPEN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT HAVE WE DO KNOW
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
IF SO PLEASE COP TO THE STANDING
MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. SEVEN OTHER
COALITION CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE THE CHRISTIANS IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BY MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MEDIA BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND SO
FORTH.
KEVIN INS CO A CALIFORNIA
INTERFAITH COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
OF JEWISH WOMEN.
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA GRACE
AND CALIFORNIA CHURCH IMPACT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN THE WATER WITH CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
TEST BARTOLO WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO I'VE BEEN ASKED.
TO GIVE SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
PATTY PRINTER BURKE FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER CRAPPIE PARENT PLACES
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
FIFTEEN CHAPTERS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN I DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MET FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW DO YOU
ENVISION THIS WORKING.
SO I MEAN ESTIMATING THE IMPACTS
OF VARIOUS POLICY AND PROGRAMS
ON CHILD POVERTY IN DEEP POVERTY.
TELL ME HOW YOU THINK THIS IS
GOING TO WORK.
THE PART OF THE WORK OF THE
LITTLE CHILDREN FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE WAS TO
PROVIDE A RANGE OF CRITERION
MEASUREMENTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN THE ONES THAT --
THE STANFORD CENTER AND POVERTY
INEQUALITY THE BUDGET CENTER PP
I SEE HAVE ALL USED. TO PROVIDE
ACTUAL MEASUREMENTS BASED ON
ESTABLISHED CRITERIA AND THE
IDEA IS TO YOU TO ESSENTIALLY
USE THOSE SAME CRITERION
MEASUREMENTS.
SO WE WILL AND IT'S NOTED THAT
THE COMMITTEE -- MAY OF SUPPORT
MAY SUGGEST SOME KIND OF PHONE
AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY THAT SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
WHAT ALREADY IS RATHER THAN.
CLEARLY WE HAVE ANYTIME
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT THE THOSE KIND
OF THEORETICAL ASPIRATIONS ARE --
BUT ARE YOU [inaudible]
IS IT.
AMERICAN PHRASES FRIED -- ARE WE
ARE WE LOOKING HERE.
TOO DO AN ACCOUNTABILITY
FRAMEWORK IS THAT WHAT THIS IS
IS THAT YOUR GOAL OR IS IT A
PROGRAMMATIC FRAMEWORK.
WILL IT.
IT'S TWO FOLD OKAY ITS FIRST.
TO ACTUALLY MEASURE PROGRESS
TOWARDS THE GOAL -- THERE IS SO
THEY KNOW THE JUST LIKE RUNNING
A BUSINESS YOU WANT YOU WANT TO
SEE IF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
WORKING AND WHETHER PERHAPS YOU
NEED TO CONSIDER OTHER THINGS
THE SECOND IS. TO LOOK AT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE PROGRAMS
THEMSELVES TO SEE.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE
JUDGMENTS ABOUT -- ARE A
PROGRAMS WORKING OR THEY AND
THEY NOT WORKING ARE THEY BEING
COST EFFECTIVE ALL OF THOSE KIND
OF ISSUES SO THAT AGAIN YOU CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE GOAL.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE
MEASUREMENTS AND CRITERIA.
THE THE THE WHAT'S THE TASK
FORCE USING THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE BILL ARE ARE ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN USED THEY CRIED AT YOU MAY
WANT TO ADD THEM IN AND AS SOON
AS THINGS MOVE FORWARD BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ARE.
USABLE PROBLEM WITH MOST
BUSINESSES THEIR MEASUREMENTS
QUITE SYMBOL ARE THEY MAKING
MONEY -- YOU KNOW THESE HEARD
THESE CRITERIA
A
REPORT THAT HELPS US TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BEST SPEND OUR OUR
VALUABLE TAX DOLLARS AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THE
MOST BANG FOR OUR BUCK.
IN REDUCING NOT CHILDHOOD
POVERTY SO THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS AND WE'LL WE'LL MAKE
SURE THAT -- AS A BILL PROCEEDS
THAT WE TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH.
THANK YOU CENTER CLEAR WE WILL
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
WE WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
YEAH. FOR THE MOTION IS -- DO
PESTICIDE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MADONNA I HURTADO AYE STONE
STONE HIGH BELL BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN LIKE PAN AYE
WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE. SIX ZERO FOUR
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CLASSIC WHAT I I'LL READ A
READ THE ITEMS ISSUE OKAY.
THE FIRST ITEM IS SB TWO
NINETEEN SENATOR WILK THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD RECOMMEND STATION TO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE SECOND ONE IS SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE SENATOR DORADO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE THIRD ONE IS SB FOUR FORTY
SENATOR PAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHAIR VOTES HI JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN PAN AYE. SIX SIX
SIX ZERO YEAH YEAH SO WITH THE
VOTE WAS SIX ZERO AND THE BILL
IS OFFICIAL.
THE CONTENT COUNTERPARTS
OFFICIALLY OUT THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
SB.
THREE NINE EIGHT SENATOR ALSO.
WELCOME SENATOR DRAWS SUIT
HEARING YOUR WITNESSES WE ASK
THAT WOULD ASSIST PEOPLE JUST
TWENTY TWO TWO TO THREE MINUTES
PLEASE.
THIS BILL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY.
IN A FOR RICHARD.
OF FROM MY CHIEF OF STAFF --
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW.
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR OF EACH
STATE TO DESIGNATE A PRIVATE.
NONPROFIT CORPORATION FOR THE
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY OF THE
RIGHTS OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES -- SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT WOULD UPDATE THAT STATE
LAW REGARDING CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCY.
TO CONFORM CALIFORNIA LAW THE
FEDERAL PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY
A AGENCY REGULATIONS THAT WERE
ADOPTED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THIS BILL ALSO
SPECIFICALLY CLARIFIES THAT THE
MEANING OF QUOTE UNQUOTE
FACILITY OR PROGRAM.
INCLUDE THE FACILITY USED TO
HOUSE OR DETAIN NON CITIZENS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CIVIL IMMIGRATION
CUSTODY.
THE STAINING THIS ACCESS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN LIGHT
OF A RECENT REPORT BY DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS CALIFORNIA'S AGENCY AND
THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
THAT REPORT WAS REGARDING THE
TREATMENT OF PERSONS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND OTHER DISABILITIES.
IN THE IMMIGRATION THESE TEND TO
IMMIGRATION -- DETENTION AT G.
E. O. GROUPS ARE THE LAN DOLE
ICE PROCESSING CENTER IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY.
AMONG OTHER FINDINGS THAT REPORT
FOUND THAT -- THE LAWN TOLL HAD
INADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
AND MEDICAL CARE FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES.
MADE ALL THE WORSE BY THE
FACILITIES COUNTERED THERAPEUTIC
CONDITIONS AND PRACTICES.
IT ALSO FOUND THAT THE G. E. O.
GROUP SIGNIFICANTLY.
UNDER REPORTS DATA ON THE NUMBER
OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS.
THAT OCCUR AT ALL DILLON.
TO THOUGH THIS MEASURE IS
UNOPPOSED CONCERNS WERE RECENTLY
RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
MY SPONSOR AND I HAVE PLEDGED TO
WORK WITH THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
PRIOR TO THE NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THIS BILL
IN SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NOW FOR WITNESSES CAN SPEAK
PLEASE.
BETTER CHECK HER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA --
AS WELL AS MAJOR BY CENTER DOOR --
SO DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S THE PROTECTION AND
ADVOCACY PROGRAM FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE LARGEST
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM --
IN THE IN THE COUNTRY -- THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL IS THAT
IT TAKES -- WHAT IS FOUND IN
THREE BASIC FEDERAL -- DIFFERENT
FEDERAL STATUTORY SCHEMES THAT
PROVIDES PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY
PROGRAMS THE ACCESS. TO
FACILITIES TO DETERMINE AND
ASSESS THE PROTECTION OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES WITH IN THOSE --
WITHIN THOSE FACILITIES SO THAT
AUTHORITY EXTENDS TO NOT ONLY --
ENTERING INTO THE FACILITIES BUT
CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN
THOSE FACILITIES SEEKING REPORTS --
ON CONDITIONS WITHIN THE
FACILITIES AND THEN ULTIMATELY --
PROVIDING REPORTS -- TO PROVIDE
SOME TRANSPARENCY WITH TO WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE THE COMMITTEES
ARE IN THE FACILITIES.
THE AUTHORITY HAS BANNED BY IN
LARGE CODIFIED WITH THE AND
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW ON IT
PROVIDES A LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY --
WITHIN -- WITHIN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER THERE WAS A SET OF
REGULATIONS -- FEDERAL
REGULATIONS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY REGULATIONS THAT WERE
PROMULGATED IN. NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THIS
BILL CODIFIES -- THOSE
REGULATIONS ALONG WITH ALL OF
THE OTHER STATUTORY AUTHORITY
AND REGULATORY AUTHORITIES THAT
EXTENT OF THIS OF FEDERAL LAW.
WE WE DO AS THE CENTER NOTED WE
DO ADD -- WITHIN THE DEFINITION
OF A FACILITY THE CIVIL
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTERS --
WE HAVE THAT AUTHORITY -- UNDER
THE FEDERAL LAW AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE TRANSPARENCY IN THAT
THAT IS NOTED WITHIN -- STATE
LAWS WELL WE HAVE BEEN IN --
MOST OF THE DETENTION FACILITIES
UNDER THIS AUTHORITY AND
CALIFORNIA AND AND VARYING
LEVELS OF OF REVIEW -- WE SPENT
TIME IN THE YOLO YOUTH FACILITY
AND ADELANTO AS WELL -- AND I
WOULD JUST -- NOTE THIS MORNING --
THE LA TIMES HAD REPORTED ON THE
TERMINATION -- BY THE CITY WITH
A CONTRACT WITH -- ICE AND AS
THEY NOTED -- A LOSS OF LAYER OF
OVERSIGHT THAT THE THAT FACILITY
MAY HAVE -- WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
AND WANT TO ENSURE THAT -- OUR
STATE LAW -- ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
AUTHORITY TO ENTER THOSE
FACILITIES WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOUR IPHONE ON THE BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANDREA RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY EIGHT
AND IN PARTICULAR -- A SPECIFIC
PROVISION OF THE BILL WHICH
WOULD EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF A
FACILITY OR PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
IMMIGRANT DETENTION CENTERS.
OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS -- TO INCREASE
OVERSIGHT OF IMMIGRANT DETENTION
FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB ONE OH THREE AND
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AB -- ONE
OH THREE MANDATES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO MONTOR AND PRODUCE A
REPORT ON THE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE FOUND IN IMMIGRANT DETENTION
FACILITIES.
AND THE AG'S OFFICE -- RELEASED
THE FIRST REPORT EARLIER THIS
YEAR IN FEBRUARY -- AND IN THE
REPORT THEY DETAIL THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT DETAINEES
OFTEN FACE WHEN ACCESSING -- OR
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS -- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THEREBY
INCREASING THE RISK ON THAT A
DETAINEE CAN EXPERIENCE A A
MENTAL HEALTH INCIDENT -- AS
NOTED BY THE ACLU -- INCIDENCES
OF SUICIDE AND DEATH AND
IMMIGRANTS TENSION FACILITIES
ARE AT AN ALL TIME HIGH.
OF FEDERAL OFFICIALS REPORT THAT
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY DETAINED
WITH MENTAL ILLNESSES AND NEED
ASSISTANCE -- HOWEVER -- HUMAN
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
CONTINUOUSLY -- REPORT --
REPEATED INSTANCES OF DETAINEES
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THE
MENTAL CARE THAT THEY DESERVE.
AMONG THE MOST RECENT TRAGIC
CASES -- MISTER JOSE ANTONIO
FRANCO GONZALEZ HE WAS A MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT WITH A SEVERE MENTAL
DISABILITY.
AND HE WAS DETAINED FOR FIVE
YEARS WITH NO -- ACCESS TO A
LAWYER OR A HEARING -- MISTER
FRANKEL GONZALEZ IS FAMILY WAS
UNABLE TO LOCATE HIM AND HE WAS
UNABLE TO COMMUNICATE TO TO HAS
A MENTAL DISABILITY.
MISTER FRANKEL GONZALEZ'S CASE
RESULTED IN WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS
THE FRANCO ROLLING.
REQUIRING LEGAL REPRESENTATION
FOR DETAINEES THAT ARE MENTALLY
IMPAIRED.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE NO ONE TO
VOUCH FOR THE CONDITIONS THAT
TAKE PLACE INSIDE THE MENTAL.
I'M SORRY INSIDE THESE
FACILITIES AND SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER --
STATE PROTECTIONS WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT -- THAT PEOPLE THAT
ARE DETAINED AND WE NEED --
MENTAL HEALTH ASSISTANCE RECEIVE
THOSE SERVICES. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT SB.
THREE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW OPEN UP A FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS BILL SB.
THREE NINE EIGHT OUR THIS BILL
DOES HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE COME UP.
RATHER STATE COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES RISING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
KEVIN AS THE COLORS CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
WE HAVE ANY.
OKAY NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYONE -- IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE NOT IS WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
NOW OKAY GREAT [inaudible]
SO. TWO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
FOR CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
OF THIS THIS SIR DISCUSSION TOOK
PLACE AND WE HAD A DISCUSSION IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH.
CAUCUSES -- ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN
A PRESENTATION AND HOW HOW WOULD
I PUT IT -- I THINK THE GENERAL
CONSENSUS WAS OUTRAGE THAT.
THESE CONDITIONS EXISTED AND
CALIFORNIA -- TO ME HE IS THE
KIND OF THING IF IF SOMETHING
WAS DONE WITH THE CHILDREN.
ESPECIALLY -- I WOULD WONDER WHY
WE DO BUSINESS WITH THEM AND
MANY OTHER AREAS SO THE KIND OF
A QUESTION.
WHETHER CONTRACTS THAT WE HAVE
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WITH COMPANIES THAT -- ONE
OBSERVER LAWS TRIGGER JEWEL IN
THIS WAY I KIND OF WONDER WHY WE
SHOULD DO BUSINESS WITH THESE
ORGANIZATIONS.
SO WE STRUCK EARLY WOULD
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THIS BILL.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO STAND UP
FOR THESE SO
OF THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE THIS IS
A HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES SO.
I WOULD STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT
FOR THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS SO HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO A CLOSE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE HAVE MOTION.
AND THE MOTION IS. TO TO PASS
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
DR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR
TITLE.
I RETIRED I STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
BEL AYE JACKSON.
PAN BY PAN AYE WIENER RIGHT
WIENER I FIVE ZERO OKAY.
THE COUNTESS FIVE ZERO AND WE
WILL I'LL HOLD THE BILL AND IT
WILL BE ON CALL [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
OUR NEXT BILL WE HAVE SENATOR
SKINNER. TWO PRESENTS SENATE
BILL.
AT THREE THREE SEVEN WELCOME
SENATOR SKINNER AND TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANKS SO MUCH.
MY WITNESSES WILL COME UP TO THE
TABLE JUST START.
SIR SB THREE THREE SEVEN DEALS
WITH THE FACT THAT IN -- THERE'S
A FEDERAL LAW.
THAT SAYS IF YOU ARE A FAMILY
THAT RECEIVES BENEFITS FOR
EXAMPLE -- WE ASK FOR
CALIBRATION THAT.
IF THERE IS A NON CUSTODIAL
PARENT PAYING CHILD SUPPORT
BENEFITS.
YOU THE FAMILY THAT IS THE
CUSTODIAL PARENT ONLY RECEIVES
FIFTY DOLLARS OF THE PAYMENT OF
THAT CHILD SUPPORT.
AND THE REMAINING CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS GOES TO THE GOVERNMENT.
TO COVER THESE BENEFITS.
AND OF COURSE IF THE
NONCUSTODIAL PARENT.
CANNOT AFFORD TO MAKE THOSE
PAYMENTS THEN FINES INTERESTING
CREW AND EVEN TO THE POINT WHERE
IT BECOMES A CRIME IS PUNISHABLE
BY RIME.
SO WHAT SB THREE THREE SEVEN
DOES IS TWO THINGS.
ONE IT.
BENEFITS THE CHILDREN BY SAYING
LOOK IF THE NONCUSTODIAL PARENT
HAS THE ABILITY TO PAY.
THEN THAT PAYMENT SHOULD GO
DIRECTLY TO THE FAMILY AND TO
COVER THE COSTS OF THE CHILDREN.
SO THE FAMILY CAN RECEIVE MORE
THAN FIFTY DOLLARS.
AND IF THAT CUSTODIAL PARENT.
NON CUSTODIAL SKEWS ME GETS IN
ARREARS.
THAT IT IS NO LONGER A CRIMINAL
FACTOR.
BUT WE CAN PURSUE AS WE DO
WONDER ARE THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA LAW. TO
TRY TO HELP COLLECT THAT --
ARREARS CHILD SUPPORT.
BUT THAT DIDN'T GET.
THAT MAY BE THAT MAY HAVE ARISEN.
DUE TO THE THIS FEDERAL LAW CAN
BE THE STATE CAN EXPANSION.
SO THEN.
THERE IS -- DE.
NON CUSTODIAL PARENT IF THEY ARE
IN A POSITION FINALLY TO BE ABLE
TO PAY THEIR AREARS CHILD
SUPPORT YOU CAN GO TO THE
CHILDREN AND IT HAS A CRUDE.
BUT THE SAD OUTRAGEOUS INTERESTS
AND SUCH WHICH BASICALLY KEEPS
THAT NON.
PARENT IN POVERTY AND BE REALLY
INABILITY TO PAY FOR THE TRUCK
HERE.
ARE THE D..
THE CHILD SUPPORT YES OKAY SO
THAT'S WHAT IT DOES AND NOW I'M
GOING TO ALLOW MY WITNESSES WHO
ARE CHRIS TO BROWN.
RIGHT FROM THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT IN SF AND RENAULT
HAMPTON FROM GROWING GREATNESS.
ALL RIGHT -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME MY NAME IS RON
I'LL HAVE TO SUPPORT IT STARTED
TO BE PRESENTING TODAY --
GROWING UP ONE OF SIX KIDS I
EXPRESS HOW HARD IT WAS FOR MY
MOTHER RAISING -- DUE TO A
FEDERAL STATE CHILD SUPPORT
POLICIES MY MOTHER ONLY RECEIVE
FIFTY DOLLARS OF THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS THAT WAS BEING GARNISHED
FROM MY FATHER'S PAYCHECK.
THAT MONEY COULD HAVE BEEN --
USED TO AVOID OUR LIGHTS IN
WATER BEING CUT OFF AT TIMES.
ARE EVEN GOING TO SUPPORT MY
COLLEGE EXPENSES WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
IS THAT MY SIBLINGS AND I HAD
TOO MUCH WERE A LOT EARLIER THAN
WE SHOULD HAVE. TO FEEL THAT
FINANCIAL GAP.
WHILE MANY OF OUR PEERS WERE
FOCUSED ON SCHOOLS WE FOUND WAYS
TO FEEL THAT FINANCIAL GAP IN
OUR HOUSEHOLD.
WE CARRY GROCERIES WE PUMP GAS.
WASH CARS IN EVEN SOLD CANDY TO
HELP OUT OUR MOM WE MISSED
TUTORING OPPORTUNITIES SPORTING
EVENTS FAMILY OUTINGS BECAUSE OF
CHILD SUPPORT POLICY.
SKINNER SAID IT BILL -- THREE
THREE SEVEN IS GOING TO ADDRESS
OUR HELP TO FIGHT RE DIRECT
THAT'S HOW SUPPORT FUNDS
DIRECTLY TO THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WHO REALLY NEED THEM
AND WHO THOSE FINES ARE INTENDED.
FOR MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
DIRECTLY REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO PUSH.
FOR AND SO THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
MOVING FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN CALIFORNIA DO NOT GET WEALTHY
EXTRACTED OUT OF THEIR FAMILIES
DUE TO TOSS SUPPORT POLICY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS CRYSTAL BROWN AND I'M WITH
THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
TREASURER'S OFFICE.
WE'VE CO AUTHORED THIS REPORT
THAT REVEALS THAT EVERY YEAR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES DO NOT RECEIVE THEIR
FULL CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
THAT'S BECAUSE FAMILIES LIKE RUN
ELSE THAT RECEIVE PUBLIC
BENEFITS ONLY GET THE FIRST
FIFTY DOLLARS OF THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS.
THE REST IS RE DIRECTED TO REPAY
THE COST OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
LIKE MEDICAID I'LL AND CAL WORKS.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA COLLECTED.
FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
WHO RECEIVED CAL WORKS THE
POOREST CHILDREN IN OUR STATE.
ONLY A FRACTION OF THOSE
PAYMENTS ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH
THE CHILDREN. 90% SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WERE REDIRECTED TO REPAY THE
COST OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
THESE POLICIES TAKE VALUABLE
RESOURCES FROM LOW INCOME
CHILDREN.
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARM CHILDREN
OF COLOR AND SET UP LOW INCOME
PARENTS TO FAIL.
WE'VE HEARD FROM COUNTLESS
FAMILIES BUT THE SYSTEM DRIVES
PARENTS TO WORK IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY SO THEY CAN
SEND THEIR EARNINGS DUE TO THEIR
FAMILY.
IT CREATES CONFLICT BETWEEN
PARENTS BECAUSE THE CUSTODIAL
PARENT OFTEN DOESN'T KNOW HOW
MUCH THE NONCUSTODIAL PARENT IS
ACTUALLY PAYING ON THEIR CHILD'S
BEHALF.
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY TAKEN
A STAND TO WRITE THIS HISTORIC
WRONG -- COLORADO IS THE FIRST
STATE TO PASS THROUGH 1100% OF
PARENTS PAYMENTS THROUGH TO
THEIR CHILDREN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS WENT UP. 63%.
PARENTS PAID NOT MORE BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THAT THE MONEY WAS
GOING TO WEAR IT SHOULD TO THEIR
CHILDREN.
I WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
SCANNERS SB THREE THREE SEVEN
AND I ENCOURAGE THE SENATORS TO
WRITE THIS IS STORK WRONG AND
PUT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES FIRST.
THANK YOU.
ARE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP
A FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
POINT.
THANK YOU JUST GIVE OUR FLOW
FROM THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY OR SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
CLICK HERE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
KEVIN AS THE COURSE OF
CALIFORNIA ROUGH ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG SUPPORT -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA NAY
WILL SPEAK FROM THE POSITION OF
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND IS THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES WE UNDERSTOOD THEN.
THE IMPORTANCE OF DOLLARS
GETTING DIRECTLY TO FAMILIES OF
THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE TRUE.
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH NUT TO CRACK
BUT THIS IS THE RIGHT BILL TO
TRYING TO THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HEY THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BUT DO WE HAVE ANYONE
SAYS IN OPPOSITION.
TO THE WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
NO OKAY. TWO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR STONE AND CENTER JACKSON
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORSKINNER -- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD.
I'M KIND OF OUTRAGE BY THIS
WHOLE PROGRAM THIS IS YOU KNOW
I'M NEW ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY THE
NONCUSTODIAL PARENT WERE BEING
DIRECTLY BENEFITING THE KIDS --
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE AMOUNT OF
HELP THAT.
THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY GET FROM
THE GOVERNMENT IS AN OFTEN
ENOUGH. TO KEEP THEM -- WHILE
TAKING CARE FIVE MINS AGO MAN
YOU'RE A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THAT
AND CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR SUCCESS IN MOVING
OUT OF POVERTY -- THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND IT ALLOWS --
CERTAINLY THE NONCUSTODIAL
PAYMENT A PAIR TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE DOING THEIR FAIR SHARE
TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR KIDS.
LOTS OF PLANTING THE THE STATE
BUDGET THAT IS GIVING MONEY WHAT
WHAT ON ANOTHER HAND.
SO -- I REALLY.
PART YOU BRING IN A FORD I'D I'D
EVEN LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR POSSIBLE BECAUSE I FEEL
SO STRONGLY ABOUT YOUR EFFORT
HERE TODAY AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
AND APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES
STEPPING FORWARD AS WELL.
THANK YOU WE WILL -- DO THAT.
ANDERSON SENATE JCKSON THANK
YOU SO IN A PRIOR LIFE IHAD THE
JOYFUL PLEASURE OF TRYING TO
COLLECT CHILD SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF CLIENTS I HAD.
THIS WAS BEFORE WE EVEN HANDED
THIS OVER TO THE DA'S OFFICE AND
THEN WE TOOK IT AWAY FROM THE
DA'S AND CREATED A SEPARATE
DIVISION OF CHILD SUPPORT
ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE COLLECTING CHILD SUPPORT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE.
SADLY SADLY PARENTS.
SHOULD UNDERSTAND AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SUPPORTING
THEIR CHILDREN -- PART OF THE
PROBLEM JUST TO TO SORT OF GIVE
SOME CONTEXT TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM TEMECULA.
WAS THAT IN THE IN THE PAST THE
NOTION THAT PEOPLE WERE ACTUALLY
HAD THE AUDACITY TO COLLECT
WELFARE.
IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT THE
WELFARE SYSTEM HAD TO BE
REIMBURSED.
AND SO THAT MONEY INSTEAD OF
GOING TO THESE CHILDREN HAD TO
GO BACK TO THE STATE. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS -- AT LEAST THAT WAS
THE POLICY BACK THEN -- LEVEL OF
POVERTY THAT YOUNG CHILDREN OR
AND OR THE CHILDREN EXPERIENCE
TODAY IS SO APPALLING.
OF THAT -- THERE'S QUESTION NO
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING THIS MY ONLY CONCERN NOW --
WILL TWO THINGS ONE IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAMMERED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT OBTAINING
THE CHILD SUPPORT COLLECTION
RATES THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED.
TO SO WE PAID ENORMOUS PENALTIES
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
AFFECTED CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTION SYSTEM SO THE MONEY
COULD GO BACK. TO THE PUBLIC
FISKE -- WE THEN I THINK AFTER A
LOT OF HARD WORK FIX THE HAVE
PROBLEM -- I'M APPALLED FRANKLY
THAT WE STILL NOT GIVING THE THE
MONEY DIRECTLY TO THE CHILDREN
SO I SHARE THAT WITH CENTER
STONE BUT THAT WAS THE ARGUMENT
IS THAT.
IF THE TAXPAYER HAS TO BE PAYING
FOR THESE CHILDREN BECAUSE A
PARENT WON'T THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THE MONEY THAT WE GET FROM
THE PARENTS AND REIMBURSE THE
STATE FOR IT AND THE CHILDREN
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE ONES WHO
SUFFERED.
THE BUT THERE'S STILL A
CHALLENGE TODAY AND I WONDERED
WHAT TWO THINGS ONE IS THAT AS
FAR AS FEDERAL LAWS CONCERN
BECAUSE WE DON'T COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW WE GET HAMMERED --
AND I'D RATHER SEE THAT MONEY
GOING TO OUR TO OUR KIDS -- THE
SECOND CONCERN I HAVE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU MAKE
CHILD SUPPORT SO ONEROUS YOU
WON'T GET THE NON CUSTODIAL
PARENT TO PAY IT.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE NON
CUSTODIAL PARENTS EXCUSES NOT TO
PAY THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
SO I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN AND
THAT'S A BALANCE IF YOU CAN
RESPOND BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU
FEEL THE SAME WAY HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE.
AND AND I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU
BECAUSE I SAW THIS HAPPEN IN IN
MY PRACTICE -- YEARS AGO -- THAT
THERE ARE NON CUSTODIAL PARENTS
WHO JUST AREN'T GOING TO PAY.
THEY DON'T WANNA.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT AND
SO THEY GO TO THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY THEY DO ALL THEIR
BUSINESS AND CASH THEY DON'T.
HAVE ANY DESIRE A SADLY TO
SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT RANKLES ME
MORE THAN THAT SO I'M WONDERING
WHAT HOW YOU AND I'M SURE THAT
RANKLES YOU TOO BECAUSE PEOPLE
NEED TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY --
HOW DOES THIS BILL ADDRESS THAT
CHALLENGE?
OUR MANAGER MAY I ANSWER.
THROUGH THE CHAIR [inaudible]
PLEASE -- THE BILL DOES NOT.
LET OFF THE HOOK THE NON
CUSTODIAL PARENT.
BUT WHAT IT DOES IS [inaudible]
SO THE SO.
DE CUSTODIAL PARENT CAN STILL
PURSUE THE COLLECTION TO THE NON
CUSTODIAL.
WHAT IT DOES IS JUST GUARANTEE
THAT WHAT EVER THE NON CUSTODIAL
PARENT PAYS GOES TO THE CHILDREN?
WHICH IS THE ABSURDITY OF OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM IN THAT WE'RE
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY WE THE
STATE TO GO AFTER AND COLLECT.
BUT THEN WHATEVER IT IS WE DO
COLLECT DOESN'T EVEN GO TO THE
CHILDREN.
AND THE THE REASON WE WERE BEING
PENALIZED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY THE FEDS IS
BECAUSE WE WERE WE HAD NOT
DISCHARGED THAT DEBT UNDER THE
LAW WE WERE ALLOWED TO DISCHARGE
THE DEBT BUT WE DIDN'T AND SO
INSTEAD WE SHOWED IT DEBT.
AND THEN WE HAD -- LOW LOW
RECOVERY OF IT.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY LOW RECOVERY
IS NOT UNUSUAL BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
BY AND LARGE PEOPLE THAT EVEN
THE NON CUSTODIAL PARENT IS NOT
NECESSARILY HIGH INCOME.
BUT CERTAINLY THERE'S EVIDENCE
AS WAS INDICATED THROUGH THE
EXPERIENCE OF COLORADO THAT ONCE
THE PARENT UNDERSTANDS THAT
THEIR ACTIONS THEIR MONEY IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO THE CHILDREN.
THEY'RE MORE WILLING TO PAY AND
MORE PAYMENT HE ACTUALLY COMES
TO THE CHILDREN SO THAT'S OUR
HOPE -- AND YES WE WOULD STILL.
WE WOULD STILL ALLOW EVERY LEGAL
RIGHT FOR THE FAMILY THE THE
CUSTODIAL PARENT TO READ.
TO RECOVER ANY OF THAT PAYMENT
THAT STILL OWED TO THEM.
OKAY I JUST -- JUST NOTE THAT
AGAIN IT DOESN'T RESOLVE THE
ENTIRE ISSUE.
BUT I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE.
TRYING TO DO AND I APPRECIATED
NOW WILL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL IN THE CENTER STONE ALREADY
DID THAT.
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT CENTERS CAN I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
ADDRESS FOR YOUR VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO I HER TITLE AYE STONE
STONE HI BEL.
BEL AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN
HI CAN I WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER HI [inaudible] SIX
ZERO THE BILL I SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT THANK THANK YOU
CENTER.
UP NEXT WE HAVE THE SENATE BILL
SIX EIGHT SEVEN BY -- SENATOR
RUBIO.
WELCOME SENATOR RUBIO AND TO
YOUR WITNESSES WEST THAT
WITNESSES GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY
TWO TO THREE MINUTES.
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN A BILL TO
INCREASE THE EFFECTIVENESS
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY OF HOMELESS
POLICIES BUT INCLUDING.
VETERANS COLLEGE.
AND PARENTS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF HOMELESSNESS IN
THE STATE'S EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THE CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS CRISIS
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR.
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE HIM -- COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD CLARIFY THAT TRAINING
BE PROVIDED TO ALL MEMBERS OF
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
FINANCING FINANCING COUNSEL
SERVES AS A STATEWIDE
FACILITATOR COORDINATOR AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT RESOURCE ON
ANTI HOMELESSNESS AND CALIFORNIA.
THE COUNCIL IS MADE UP OF
SEVENTEEN MEMBERS REPRESENTING
GOVERNMENTAL DEPARTMENTS AND
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS AND
ONLY TWO MEMBERS WOULD LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF HOMELESSNESS ONE
FORMERLY HOMELESS PERSON AND ONE
FORMERLY HOMELESS YOUTH.
ALL OF THESE GROUPS COLLEGE
STUDENTS VETERANS AND PARENTS
MAKE UP SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
HOMELESS POPULATION AND THEIR
VOICES DESERVE TO BE HEARD.
EACH OF THESE NEW APPOINTEES
WILL BRING A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
TO HELP ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOME IS CRISIS AND TODAY I'M
HONORED TO HAVE WITH ME.
MADE VASQUEZ -- A FORMALLY
HOMELESS FERRET VETERAN WHO IS
HERE TO SHARE HIS LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH THE HOMELESSNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS NAY BUSCAS AND I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO.
TODAY I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
MY LIVED EXPERIENCES WITH
HOMELESSNESS.
I HAD A DIFFICULT CHILDHOOD.
AT AGE EIGHTEEN I JOIN THE
MARINE CORPS AS AN INFANTRYMAN.
I WAS DEPLOYED TO IRAQ IN
ADDITION OPERATIONS IN KOSOVO
AND THE ONE OF AFRICA.
MY SERVICE CONNECTED INJURIES
INCLUDE EPILEPTIC DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES.
AND POSTER MATIC STRESS DISORDER.
AFTER MY ENLISTMENT I DID MY
BEST OVERCOME THESE CONDITIONS.
I WAS MARRIED AND HAD TWO SONS.
I HAD GOOD JOBS AND ATTENDED UC
DAVIS ON A FULL SCHOLARSHIP.
BUT THE AFFECT MY PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL CONDITIONS HAD ON MY
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND MY ABILITY TO GO TO WORK IN
SCHOOL WAS OVERWHELMING.
AND IT WASN'T ALWAYS EASY FOR ME
TO ACCESS MEDICAL TREATMENT AND
MEDICATIONS.
AFTER LAPSING IN TREATMENT AND
MEDICATIONS MY WIFE LEFT ME.
I LOST MY JOB.
I DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND WAS EVICTED FROM SEVERAL
APARTMENTS.
I BECAME ALMOST.
AT FIRST I GOT SERVED WITH
FRIENDS BUT I ALWAYS LEFT BEFORE
IT OVER TAX MY FRIENDSHIPS.
I SOMETIMES A STATE IN CHEAP
MOTELS SHELTERS.
EXCUSE ME.
OFTEN I WAS ON SHELTERED.
I EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE AND
DISCRIMINATION WHEN I WAS
HOMELESS.
WITHOUT TREATMENT AND
MEDICATIONS I BEGAN.
TO EXPERIENCE -- SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS.
IN MY BEHAVIOR BECAME VERY
AGGRESSIVE.
HAD RIGHT REGULAR ALTERCATIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I WAS CONSTANTLY IN JAIL AND
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES.
I WAS READY TO GIVE UP ON MYSELF
AND CASH IN HAND.
BUT THEN I WAS OFFERED ADMISSION
TO THE SACRAMENTO VETERANS
TREATMENT CORD.
VETERANS STREAM COURT IS A
RIGOROUS TREATMENT PRO --
TREATMENT AND SUPERVISION
PROGRAM IT REQUIRES PARTICIPANTS.
TO FORM AND FOLLOW THE TREATMENT
PLAN WITH THE A PROVIDERS
MENTORSHIP FROM A FELLOW VETERAN.
AND PROBATION SUPERVISION.
AFTER A LOT OF HARD WORK TRIALS
AND TRIBULATIONS I GRADUATED
FROM THE PROGRAM.
HELLO VETERANS TREATMENT COR
COMMUNITY HAS BECOME MY FAMILY.
I STILL PARTICIPATE AS AN ALUMNI.
I'M WELL INTEGRATED INTO
TREATMENT AT THE VA.
HAVE GOOD RELATIONSHIPS WITH MY
PROVIDERS AND PEERS.
AND I HAVE HEALTHY AND POSITIVE
INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE V. A HELP ME TO GET AN
APARTMENT.
SO NOW I'M ABLE TO SPEND TIME
WITH MY SON TO BE THE FATHER
THEY NEED.
AND I AM ALSO VOLUNTEERING IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND SUPPORTING MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN THE VETERAN COMMUNITY.
MY EXPERIENCES ARE NOT
EXCEPTIONAL.
HOMELESSNESS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS VETERANS AND PERSONS
WITH MENTAL AND NEUROLOGICAL
ILLNESSES.
IF EXPERIENCE IN CHILDREN'S.
EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS.
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES.
I VALUE SENATOR REVEALS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL INCLUDE VOICES
LIKE MINE FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LIVED EXPERIENCES WITH
HOMELESSNESS TO SHARE.
IN THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
JOB WILL NOW OPEN -- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS BILL.
I'M I'D LIKE TO INVITE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT ARE
HERE.
NOW NONE OKAY.
OF THE HARD QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
NOW OKAY.
SENATOR RUBIO IT IN FACT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION YOU INDICATED
YOU ATTENDED VETERANS TREATMENT
COURT IS -- IT WAS SAID IN
ORANGE COUNTY -- SACRAMENTO IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
WELL AS A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
STREET IN COURT YOUR GOOD
EXAMPLE CONGRATULATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR RUBIO WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU WELL FIRST OF ALL ON
IT THANK MADE VASQUEZ FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO COME AND TELL HIS
STORY AND DOWN.
ON BEHALF OF NATE AND ALL THE
OTHER HOMELESS POPULATIONS I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO WE HAVE
A MOTION -- BY SENATOR PAN TO DO
PROPER.
CENTER ABOUT PARDON ME.
I DO PASS AS AMENDED TO US
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE US
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL I FOR TITLE I STONE.
STONE I'D BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE
WIENER.
WIENER AYE. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
ANGELES OUT THANK YOU AGAIN.
SO UP NEXT WE HAVE [inaudible]
YEAH.
SENATOR WIENER ON US TO PRESENT
SB
[inaudible]
TWO SIX EIGHT AFTER.
CONSIDERED NGUYEN PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE COLLEAGUES -- SB.
TWO SIXTY EIGHT ELIMINATES THE
CASH ASSET TEST IN THE VEHICLE
ACCESS ASSET TO THE VEHICLE
ASSET TESTING CAL WORKS.
ARE CURRENTLY -- FOR CAL WORKS
ARE RECIPIENT -- AN APPLICANT IS
ALLOWED TO HAVE NO MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS.
IN CASH ASSETS IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR CAL WORKS IF.
A PERSON HAS THE GALL TO
ACCUMULATE ANY ADDITIONAL
SAVINGS BEYOND THAT -- THEY'RE
NO LONGER THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR CAL WORKS.
IN ADDITION -- THE VEHICLE ASSET
TEST FOR CAL WORKS.
LIMITS -- THE VALUE OF SOMEONE'S
CAR TO NINE THOUSAND AND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO IF THE CAR
HAPPENS TO BE WORTH MORE THAN
THAT THE CAR THEY USED TO GO TO
WORK OR TO SCHOOL -- THEN -- YOU
ARE -- INELIGIBLE -- BE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ODD VALUES ASSET
TESTS WHICH ARE NOT REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW -- IS HUGE -- A
RECENT STUDY BY HOWARD
UNIVERSITY ESTIMATED -- COST
SAVINGS OF ELIMINATING THE ASSET
TO US -- AT A HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
DISCOURAGED FROM SAVING.
MONEY -- BY THIS ASSET TEST.
WE SHOULD BE WANTING -- LOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO TRY TO MOVE OUT
OF POVERTY AND YOU DO THAT -- BY
SAVING MONEY -- BUT IF SAVING
MONEY MEANS YOU NO LONGER GET
BENEFITS -- THAT'S A HUGE
DISINCENTIVE TO SAVING -- WE
ALSO KNOW -- THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE COURSE NEED THEIR CAR
JUST TO SURVIVE.
SO WE SHOULD NOT BE CREATING AN
INCENTIVE -- NOT TO HAVE A CAR
OR TO HAVE A CAR -- THAT BROWN'S
DOESN'T WORK SO WELL -- OTHER
STATES -- IN THE U. US OF PASSED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION -- TO MOVE
AWAY FROM HIS ASSET TESTS AND
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DO THE SAME
AGAIN IT'S NOT REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW -- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OR JUST PART OF THE LOWER HALF
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AND BECKY GROSJEAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BACK
YOUR SON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS I'M WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO TO SIXTY EIGHT ON OUR
NETWORK OF FORTY ONE FOOD BANKS
IN OVER SIX THOUSAND AGENCY
PARTNERS HOP AND MISSION TO END
HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA -- AND WE
KNOW THAT AMONGST THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES THAT
ACCESS FREE GROCERIES EVERY DAY.
I'M CAL WORKS FAMILIES ARE
AMONGST THE POOREST OF THOSE
THAT COME TO OUR RESOURCE
CENTERS.
AND THE COLORS PROGRAM IS JUST
ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT THIS THAT
OUR STATE HAS IN ADDRESSING DEEP
POVERTY.
BUT IT'S FLAWED AS YOU HEARD I'M
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF ENCOURAGING
FAMILIES TO SAVE RESOURCES AND
GROW THEIR FINANCIAL STABILITY
AND ACTUALLY DISCOURAGES EFFORTS
TOWARD SELF SUFFICIENCY --
CURRENTLY THE COLOR EXTRA
PROGRAM BASICALLY REQUIRES A
FAMILY TO HAVE HIT ABSOLUTE ROCK
BOTTOM.
BEFORE THEY CAN GET REALLY
MODEST.
AMOUNTS OF AID AND FOOD BANKS
ARE PART OF THE SAFETY NET THAT
STOPS IN WHEN PEOPLE REALLY
DON'T HAVE OTHER OPTIONS -- AND
WHEN GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE MEANT TO KICK IN IN THESE
TIMES I HAVE FAILED THEM.
I'M SO THE IDEA THAT FAMILIES
ALREADY LIVING ON THE EDGE OF
POVERTY OR DISCOURAGED OR EVEN
PENALIZED FOR HAVING MODEST
SAVINGS IS BOTH CRUEL ANYTHING
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
I AM SO THE COUNT THE CALORIES
GRANTS ARE MEANT TO HELP
FAMILIES GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
AND IN ORDER TO STAY TRUE TO
THAT MISSION -- WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO REPEAL
THE ASSET TEST SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS AS WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO ASK
ABOUT THE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY I'M
ALSO THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE FOR THIS
STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA ASSET
BUILDING COALITION -- THAT'S
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AS YOU HEARD THIS POLICY AT NOT
ONLY DISCOURAGES SAVINGS.
BUT IT SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE
NOT JUST TAKE OUR SHE SAID PANTS
BUT ALSO TO THE COMMUNITY.
WE EVE YOU SEEN US IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE YOU SEEN US AND POLICY
COMMITTEE THAT -- TESTIFY TIME
AND TIME AGAIN THAT PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE CAO WORKS RECEIVE JUST.
NOT EVEN ENOUGH TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS.
AND IT'S IT'S DEFINITELY OUR
EXPERIENCE THAT THE ASSET TEST --
DOESN'T HURT MOST THE PEOPLE ON
A BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO LITTLE.
THEY CAN BARELY TAKE CARE OF
WHAT THEY NEED TO PAY TODAY I AM
NOT TO MENTION PUT AWAY SAVINGS
BUT IT DOES HURT THE MOST BY THE
APPLICANTS.
NOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
THE APPLICANTS COMING IN IT'S
LESS THAN 1% OF APPLICANTS TO
ACTUALLY END UP N -- BEING
DENIED BENEFIT BECAUSE OF THIS
ROLE.
BUT A 100% OF THE APPLICANTS
ACTUALLY HAVE TO SHOW THEIR
PAPERWORK AND AND EITHER PROVE
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ASSETS OR
THAT THEIR ASSETS ARE LOW ENOUGH
AND A 100% OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS.
WHO RECEIVE THOSE APPLICANTS --
HAVE TO DO THE SAME AND THAT'S
TIME AWAY FROM HELPING PEOPLE
FIND HOMES HELPING THEM REMOVE
BARRIERS TO WORK HELPING THEM
APPLY FOR THEIR WELFARE TO WORK
PLACEMENT.
EVERY A 100% OF THE APPLICANTS
HAVE TO GOING GET COPIES OF THE
BANK STATEMENTS IF THEY DON'T
HAVE A BANK STATEMENT THEY HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO PROVE
THEY DON'T HAVE A BANK STATEMENT.
AGAIN -- YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT
THE EFFICIENCIES THAT CAN BE
GAINED BY REMOVING THE ASSET
TEST AND THE HAVE BEEN GAINED IN
STATES THAT HAVE DONE SO AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THOSE EFFICIENCIES
CAN BE PLOWED BACK INTO THE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE.
BETTER SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE COMING
IN AND APPLYING FOR ASSISTANCE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO HIT THE FLOOR.
BEFORE THEY GET A LITTLE HELP SO
WITH THAT WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR SAFETY NET AND
AND SUPPORT FAMILIES WHO ARE
COMING IN AND SEEKING AID -- ED
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN STABILITY
THANKS.
THANK YOU WILL NOW OPEN UP.
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS BILL
DO WE HAVE ANY.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHIME FRANK MAKE
IT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ONE STRONG SUPPORT --
INCOME AND RESOURCES ARE WHAT
PEOPLE NEED TO MOVE TO POVERTY
IN OUR WORKERS AND MEMBERS OF
RATHER SPEND TIME HELPING PEOPLE
MOVE TOWARD SELF SUFFICIENCY GET
JOBS.
THAN CHASING PAPER THAT SUGGESTS
SERVING TO IMPOVERISHED PEOPLE
THANKS.
AND JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
IN ORDER SEVEN AS THE CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT.
GEN AND CAL WORKS WITH STUDENTS
WHO ARE ON WELFARE HAVE NORM
LAST WEEK OF THE MONTH THEY
STARVE THEY HAVE NOTHING TO SAVE.
NOW AND THEN SOMEBODY MAKE IT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM A
RELATIVE OR WHATEVER AND THEN
THEY CUT THEM OFF TO HAVE JUST
IT DOESN'T.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE SO WITH
SUPPORTERS BUILDING -- CHILD
JUST BILL YOUR RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY I DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
HERBAL.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST EVILS OF THE WORKS.
SYSTEM -- SAID I NOTICES SEARCH
STONE HAS TRIED TO DO WITH THIS
I TRY TO DO IT WE WE WE'VE HAD A
A PROBLEM IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE
[inaudible]
THAT.
ACTUALLY HELPING PEOPLE.
CREATE OUT SAYS IS A GOOD THING
I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I I DON'T UNDERSTAND THEM I
NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE METHODOLOGY
OF THE APPROPRIATORS.
IN CONCERN THAT CAN YOU COMMENT
ON THAT WHICH YEAH THIS IS.
THIS IS LIKE A HISTORICAL
PROBLEM WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES -- I AM I RIGHT AND
CAN YOU COMMENT ON HOW WE CAN
OVERCOME.
AT THAT THIS INFORMATION I THINK
THAT'S IN -- WHAT I CONSIDER A
FAULTY WAY OF LOOKING AT?
THIS ISSUE FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES.
SENATE RECORD COMMON FOR A
LENGTHY PERIOD OF TIME ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATION PROCESS WE'VE WE
ALWAYS HAVE PROBLEMS WE HAVE AND
WE HAVE FAN.
TASTIC CURRENT AND FORMER TEARS
OF THE PROVISIONS COME TO YOU
AND I OF COURSE FOR MEMBERS.
OF THE COMMITTEE WITH INCREDIBLE
STAFF BUT I I'M.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
THINGS HAPPEN IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS THAT --
IT IT YOU KNOW -- TOM CLEAR WHY
AND I THINK SOMETIMES WHENEVER
YOU HAVE A BIG PRICE TAG.
IT DOES -- IT'S THE DOLLARS
BECAUSE FOCUS IN TERMS OF BEING
HELD IN SUSPENSE -- SO I WE HAVE
MADE A BUDGET REQUESTS I'M NOT
GOING TO PUT THE CHAIR OF THAT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE SPOT
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE RIGHT HERE -- BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY MAKING A BUDGET REQUEST --
AND TRYING TO GET THIS FUNDED IN
THE BUDGET AND IF THAT MEANS
THAT THE BILL GETS ABSORBED INTO
THE BUDGET -- I BE -- HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT HAPPEN -- BUT WERE
PRETTY DETERMINED TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THIS YEAR.
HELLO MISS BARTOLO WOULD LIKE TO
I DON'T.
WHAT THE MISSION COMMON ABOUT?
HOW COME WE'VE HAD HAVE THEY
LOOKED AT IT WRONG IN TERMS OF
THE WAY THE ANALYZE?
THE THE COST I THINK IT SAVES
MONEY WHEN YOU [inaudible]
THE STATE.
ALLOW SAVINGS THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE WE WANT.
WE WANT -- TO ENCOURAGE CAL
WORKS -- ORANGE TO HELP THEIR
CHILDREN AND HAVE A WAY TO HAVE
A TRANSPORTATION -- YEAH
WILLIAMS SO LOOK FOR CENTER BELT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA IN THE PAST AND PASS --
LEGISLATION.
PROPOSALS -- YOU KNOW I THINK IN
GENERAL THERE'S A A PROPENSITY
TO TO SITE -- COST PRESSURES WE
ALWAYS HEAR THIS THIS COST
PRESSURES AS COST PRESSURES AND
I ALWAYS.
TRY TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THERE'S ALSO SAVINGS PRESSURES --
AND AND THE SAVINGS PRESSURES ON
OFTEN GET IDENTIFIED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHEN WE
WE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW IT WE
WON'T HAVE TO SPEND SO MUCH ON
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE IF FAMILIES
CAN HAVE A LITTLE CUSHION. TO
COVER THE RENT WHEN THEIR WAGES
ARE SHORT.
IF WE CAN LOOK AT THE SAVINGS
PRESSURES. FOR THESE TYPES OF OF
PROGRAMS FOR AND HOW THEY IMPACT
LOW INCOME FAMILIES I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT BENEFIT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO JOIN US AND
REQUESTING.
THOSE KINDS OF CONSIDERATIONS.
OR THROUGH THE BILL THANK YOU.
SENATOR STONE AND THEN CENTER
MAN THEY GIVE THEM CHAIR --
SENATOR WIENER -- THE ASSESSED
VALUE OF MORE THAN NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED WITH THE VEHICLE I
SENATE'S THE NET VALUE -- OF THE
VEHICLES IS BECAUSE I REPORTS
HAS ASSESSED VALUE SO YOU CAN
HAVE A NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR VEHICLE BUT THE ONLY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON THE VEHICLE
THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT THE DELTA
THAT WERE.
INGRATIATING THESE PEOPLE WITH
RIGHT SO I SO IT'S NOT VALUE.
THE CURRENT THE CURRENT --
PROPOSAL IS JUST TO REPEAL THE
ASSET TEST AND THEY ASKED AND
THE VEHICLE A TEST AS PART OF
PART AND PARCEL OF THE ASSET
TEST SO JUST REPEAL IT -- AND IT
WOULD SAY WE'RE NOT GOING T
GATHER INFORMATION ABOUT THE
BLUE BOOK VALUE OF YOUR CAR.
OR YOUR SYSTEM A LOT TODAY YEAH
UNDER THE THE VALUES ASSESSED AT
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED THE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE BALANCES
OWED ON THAT IT'S JUST THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU OWE WE ACTUALLY.
CHANGE THAT LAW WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS AND A
COUPLE OF BUDGETS AGO WHERE WE
IT USED TO BE THAT THE VALUE OF
THE CAR.
TOTAL AND WE CHANGED IT TO BE --
JUST THE THE AMOUNT THE PERSON
OLD IN THE VALUE.
OF ENOUGH VALUE.
OKAY.
I THINK TELEVISION ABOUT IT YEAH
IF I OKAY WHICH IS BETTER -- I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO -- I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE DISCOURAGED FROM FROM
SAVINGS AND TRYING TO LIFT
THEMSELVES OUT OF A POVERTY -- I
THINK THIS FORCES PEOPLE TO TO
LIVE ON THE EDGE WHICH I THINK
IS WRONG -- BUT AM I SAYING THIS
IS GOING TO BE PREVALENT AMONG
THIS POPULATION BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IF SOMEBODY COMES INTO AN
INHERITANCE WE ARE IF I MENTION
FIVE THOUSAND THAT'S NOT.
AS MUCH MONEY AS I WAS THINKING
SUMMIT IT A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR SHOULD THERE NOT BE SOME
TEST.
OF THEIR CASH ON HAND UNDER THE
PENALTY OF PERJURY THEY DON'T
HAVE TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
CASH ON HAND -- SO THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY GAMING THE
SYSTEM.
I THINK IF YOU.
IF YOU HAVE IF YOU COMING OF
THAT LEVEL OR A HIGH LEVEL OF
WEALTH.
COULD BE THE CASE YOU'RE GONNA
BE GENERATING INCOME.
OFF OF THAT MOST LIKELY AND THAT
INCOME MAY BY ITSELF.
DISQUALIFY. FOR OVERLOOKED SAID
EXTREME EXAMPLE AND IF SOMEONE
HURTS MILLION DOLLARS YOU'RE
PREGNANT URINE MAKING WAY TOO
MUCH YOU CAN BE ONE OF THOSE OF
ALL SOMEBODY AUGUSTINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TWENTY THOUSAND THE CAN
INTO IT YOU KNW IT RATE TO THE
BANK TODAY AT QUARTER PERCENT OR
1%.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET THAT KIND
OF MEN COMPRESSION I'M SORRY.
DO WE NEED SOME KIND OF A
ESTONIA TO MAKE SURE THAT.
I GUESS HELPING ALL PEOPLE THAT
REALLY NEED OUT I GUESS MY TAKE
ON IT IF YOU US OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN POVERTY WHO ARE ON CAL WORKS.
AND LET'S SAY BEEN HURT FIFTEEN
OR TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THAT'S MONEY BUT LET'S SAY THEY
SAY PUT THAT IN SAVING SO
KICKING A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
THEY CAN -- PAY SOME BILLS WITH
THEIR BEHIND OR WHATEVER OR THEY
JUST KEEP IN SAVINGS IN CASE
THEY NEED A FOR RENT ONE DAY.
I DON'T.
THAT DOESN'T DOESN'T BOTHER ME
AT ALL I THINK IF A NATURAL
LIMIT IF YOU'RE.
HAVING TO BE IN HURTING SO MUCH
MONEY.
THAT IT WOULD REALLY SEEM
OBSCENE THEY'RE GONNA THE
INTEREST ON THAT IS PROBABLY
GOING TO DISQUALIFY THEM.
FROM RECEIVING CAL WORKS -- SO I
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
BEEN NICK'S RAMPS AND OTHER
STATES THAT DON'T HAVE TE ASSET
TEST.
ON BECAUSE FORTUNATELY EVEN.
CALIFORNIA WE LIKE TO THINK OF
OURSELVES ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
A LOT OF ISSUES BUT I'VE LEARNED
SINCE COMING UP HERE THAT THERE
A LOT OF ISSUES WERE WERE.
LIGHTING OTHER STATES INCLUDING
SOME RED STATES -- AND THIS IS
ONE OF THEM AND SO FORTUNATELY
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE THE TEST
CASE WE KNOW HOW IT'S WORKED
OTHER STATES AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S BEEN AN ISSUE.
I WOULD JUST SAID THAT THE
RESEARCH DOES BEAR THAT OUT THAT --
IN THE OTHER STATES TO HAVE
PASSED AS THE TOWN OF ASSET TEST
REPEALED THEY HAVE NOT HAVE
EXPANSION IN THERE AT TEN OF
POPULATION -- AND I WOULD ADD
THAT PEOPLE -- PEOPLE WHO
INHERIT A LOT OF WEALTH PROBABLY
HAVE OTHER WAYS LIKE TAX CREDITS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT TO TAKE A
NOTE TO BENEFIT AT THIS AND WHEN
YOU GO TO APPLY FOR PUBLIC
BENEFITS YOU HAVE TO COMPLY WITH.
THE WELFARE TO WORK RULES YOU
HAVE TO IT A GIVE AWAY ALL THE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR HOUSEHOLD
YOUR PRIVACY THIS IS A VERY IT'S
A IT'S A SYSTEM IN WHICH TO OPEN
UP ALL YOUR VULNERABILITIES.
AND SOMEBODY HAS EXTREME WEALTH
THEY WERE NOT SUBJECT THEMSELVES
TO THAT KIND OF SCRUTINY IN
ORDER TO GET A COUPLE HUNDRED
BUCKS OF A MONTH THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER WAYS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS GIVING THEM AN
EXTRA COUPLE HUNDRED BUCKS A
MONTH.
WITH THAT KIND OF WEALTH -- AT
AND FINALLY I WOULD SAY THIS
POLICY IF PASSED A LINES ARE
ASSET TEST WITH FEDERAL LAW. FOR
CAL FRESH AND WITH FEDERAL LAW
FOR MEDICARE MEDICARE RECIPIENTS
HAT WITH CHILDREN ALSO HAVE
WAIVED AS A TEST SO WE ALIGN ALL
THREE PROGRAMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND SAID SHE CALLED ME
ON THE FIGURED I THIS.
IS NOT BY NAME NOW THAT IT AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS -- THE IT
DOES NOT APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ACTUALLY IS PRESENT
RIGHT HERE -- THE BUT I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU.
AND I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE CROSSES
OF NAY CROSS THE LINE TO THE
MONEY SIDE BUT IT IS SO HOW MANY --
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT TO GET EXCLUDED FROM THE
ACID TEST?
BIKE I MEAN -- SO I I CERTAINLY
GET I GET THE POINT THAT IT
COSTS TO STEAL OUR MONEY TO DO
IT TO GO AND ASK THE QUESTIONS
AND REQUIRE PEOPLE RIGHT PROOF
AND ALL THIS OTHER STUFF.
AND IN THE END AFTER WE PUT
PEOPLE THROUGH THE RINGER FOR
THAT HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE
SIMPLY SAVE UP TOO MUCH TOO BAD
TO GO AND I REALIZE THAT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE MAYOR RIGHT NOW
SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TRY BUT
YOU KNOW I'M.
I'M TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF
LIKE FROM THAT HE SAID OTHER
STATES TO TRY THIS EXACTLY HOW
THE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT IT AT
ALL -- I'LL ASK ON THIS PORTAL
TO ANSWER THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED IS IS A BIGGER ISSUE --
IT'S IT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
WHO'S GETTING KICKED OFF IT'S
ABOUT PEOPLE SAYING WELL I I
BETTER NOT SAVE ANY MONEY OR
GOING TO LOSE.
MY BENEFITS IT WAS SORT OF THE
MESSAGE THAT IT SENDS AND SO THE
BABY THEY NEVER GET HER TALKED
BUT THEY'RE NOT SAVING MONEY.
AND AND IT'S IN OUR LETTER OF
SUPPORT BUT IT THAT THE THE
EXTENSIVE RESEARH ON THIS TOPIC --
BUT LOOK BUT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
LESS THAN 1% OF THE APPLICANTS --
THE WORK OF 100% OF APPLICANTS
WITH LESS THAN 1% ACTUALLY EVER
BEING DENIED ON THE CURRENT NOW
WITH THE CURRENT -- LAW SO SO
I'M JUST A YEAR AND THE THINKING
ABOUT EVEN ON THE MONEY SIDE
REALIZING THIS THE POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT BUT SINCE YOU
REFERENCE THE BUDGET -- T A
PART OF ME IS THIS THINKING LIKE
WELL THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE
SAVING.
BY.
DECREASING THE OVERHEAD IN THE
PROCESS.
IS THAT I MEAN AND HOW THAT
COMPARES WITH DID NOT OF QUOTE
MONEY THAT WE'RE GONNA SPEND
EXTRA BECAUSE WE'VE INCREASES
OUR CASELOAD I GUESS THAT'S
GONNA BE I MEAN OF WHAT WHAT'S
GENERATING THE EXPENSE.
IN THIS BILL I MEAN I RELIZE
THIS IS.
THAT'S FRIES THAT THAT'S A
LITTLE MAYBE A LITTLE MORE PREP
SITE QUESTION BUT AND YOU KNOW
BUT I'M JUST THE END AND I THINK
PART OF THESE GOING LIKE WELL
IT'S ONLY 1% HOW MANY MORE HOW
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE COULD THIS
BE TO DO THIS BILL THEN.
THE NOT RIGHT AND HOW THE WORD
IS APPROPRIATIONS PEOPLE EQUITY
HOW DID HOW COME HOW DID THEY
SAY WHY DO THEY SEE THIS
EXPENSIVE.
SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT LIKE A MEGA
EXPENSIVE I AM I'M ASKING SIGNED
THE LETTER I THINK IT WAS GOING
ON ALRP [inaudible] EIGHT
MILLION.
OKAY -- IT'S IT'S I DON'T THINK
IT'S A MEGA EXPENSE BUT OF
COURSE THE WAY THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS WORKS IS.
YOU KNOW YOU IT EVEN IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SAVE MORE THAN YOU
SPEND THAT DOESN'T TAKE YOU OUT.
OF SECONDS RIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL
WELL WELL AS IT SINCE THERE'S A
BUDGET REQUEST OF BE INTERESTED
LOOKING AT BOTH SIDES OF THAT.
WE DID THAT THANK YOU YOU CENTER
CONSIDER JACKSON.
THANK YOU -- HI.
I APPRECIATED WE'RE TALKING THE
POTENTIAL FOR ABUSES TO MINIMUS
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETIMES ALL TEXAS
AT ONE BAD EXAMPLE AND THEN
SUDDENLY A PROGRAM IS UNDERMINED --
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
EITHER SO I'M WONDERING -- IS
THERE SOME KIND OF ON GOING
BASIS SO IN OTHER WORDS TO FIGHT --
DISCOVER I HAVE A REACHING OUT.
OF BECAUSE I'VE JUST INHERITED.
A LET'S SEE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR LET'S SAY A HOUSE --
IS THERE SOMETHING UNDER
EXISTING CAL WORKS RULES THAT
REQUIRES IF I WERE TO COME INTO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO REPORT IT IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE IF THAT'S THE
CASE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THIS.
I DON'T MY TWENTY THOUSAND I
DON'T MIND. THIRTY BUT I'M THE
WORD TO AND WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE THE PEOPLE WHO GET TO
TAKE TAX CREDITS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU THE THOSE PEOPLE I'M NOT AT
ALL CONCERNED BUT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO IN SOME POINT.
FIND THAT THEY GET TO COME INTO
SOME LEVEL OF I WILL CALL IT
WEALTH BUT SOME LEVEL OF THE
THAT YOU KNOW BENEFIT.
THAT THAT IS SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH
THAT IT MIGHT.
HAVE AFFECTED THEIR CAL WORKS IF
THEY YOU HAD REPORTED.
WELL I I THINK THAT IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THE
LET'S SAY.
FIFTY THOUSAND A SOME MAY HAVE
SOME POINT AGAIN THAT THE INCOME
THAT YOU'RE EARNING FROM THAT
WEALTH IS GOING TO DISQUALIFY
YOU FROM.
FROM CAL WORKS AND I I ALSO I DO
AGREE WITH THE WITHIN PARCEL OF
THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RECEIVING A PRETTY MODEST AMOUNT
OF MONEY CAL WORKS IS NOT IN ARE
NOT RECEIVING A LOT OF MONEY PER
MONTH -- INTO THAT THE AYE I
THINK IT WOULD BE.
REALLY REALLY EXCEPTIONAL THAT
SOMEONE HAS COME INTO
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY SO
LET ME GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE ALL RIGHT LET'S ASSUME
AS HYPOTHETICAL THAT SOMEONE
COMES INTO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM AN UNCLE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
THERE ON CAL WORKS TODAY OF ANY
ROUTE LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY TO
REPORT THAT MONEY.
UNDER THIS BILL NOW.
TODAY HAVE HOWEVER IF THEY PUT
INTO AN ACCOUNT AND THEY DREW
DOWN THE MONEY ON A MONTHLY
BASIS TO PAY THEIR BILLS IT
WOULD IT WOULD BE COUNTED UNDER
CURRENT LAW AS INCOME SO IF THE
MONEY SAT IN THE ACCOUNT IF THIS
BILL PASSED.
ON THE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AT THE COUNT THEY DIDN'T
TOUCH IT THEY COULDN'T USE IT.
BUT IF THE BUT YOU KNOW IT WITH
THAT CONTINUE TO RECEIVE AID BUT
IF IT IF THEY DO THAT MONEY DOWN --
AT AND MORE THAN OCE THEN THEY
WOULD END UP HAVING TO COUNT AS
INCOME.
UNDER UNDER THE LAW CURRENTLY
AND IF PASSED RESOURCES DRAWN
DOWN -- FROM AN ACCOUNT ON A
REGULAR BASIS COUNT NOT ONLY FOR
FOR AT CAL EXPENDABLE ALSO FOR
COVERAGE BENEFITS -- SO SO THAT
HAVE HAD A SELF REPORT I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE THE AT TWO
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEY GOT THE
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS --
AND I YOU KNOW I JUST HAS A LIKE
LACKEY THEM FOR THEIR UNCLE
ACTUALLY MY UNCLES AT WHAT THEY
LEAVE ME IS NOT ANY OF THAT --
BUT IF THEY I'M HAPPY TO BE IN
ADOPTED.
BUT LET'S ASSUME THAT HAPPENS
THAT IF THEY GET INSTANCE WHERE
DOES AND SUDDENLY OKAY THING
WILL BE SO IF THEY GOT THEY GOT
THE MONEY TODAY THAT HAVE TO
REPORTED TODAY -- AS AN ASSET
AND IT WOULD MAKE THEM ELIGIBLE
IMMEDIATELY BUT IF THEY GOT IT
AND IF THIS BILL PASSED AND THEY
GOT THE MONEY THEY WOULDN'T
REPORT IT AS AN ASSET THE MINUTE
THEY STARTED DRYING IT DOWN TO
USE IT THEY HAVE TO REPORT IT AS
INCOME -- AND AND THAT INCOME
WOULD HAVE TO BECOME A INCLUDE
SOUNDS AND CAL WORKS OR SNAP.
HOW FASHION COLORS AND SO THAT
MY HOPE YOU YEAH IT DOES A YEAR
JUST THERE HAS TO BE SOME?
SOME PROTECTION THERE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW I DON'T HEAR THE WORD
WELFARE QUEEN ONE MORE TIME AND
YOU KNOW.
THAT WHAT THE IF YOU.
IF EVERYTHING IS SO OPEN AND
NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF PEOPLE
ARE FOLLOWING THE RULES IT'S
THAT ONE TENTH 1% THAT HURT YOU
AND SO I WILL I AM HOPING WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE AN ENDO AND
THE OTHER STATES TO DO THIS THIS
IS NOT BEEN.
AN ISSUE SO THAT I CAN ALWAYS BE
EXTREME SITUATION.
WELL IT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
HAVE SO THERE HAS TO BE THERE IS
A REPORTING MECHANISM IN ALL
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL.
NOT CONTINUE THAT TRADITION AS
WATER BELGIUM FOR THE CRIMES.
THAT THE THE TYPE OF AREAS WHERE
YOU COULD SAVE IS -- IS IN TERMS
OF THE SIMPLIFICATION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
IS IT BE CONSISTENT WITH THE CAL
WORKS PROCESS THE CAL FRESH
PROCESS SO.
I THINK -- CHILD CHILD CARE.
PROGRAMS YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS BE ALL THE
SAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL.
DOES THAT WHEN THEY HAVE TO THE
ELIGIBILITY WORKER AT THE COUNTY
WHEN THEY HAVE TO GO BACK AND
CHECK ASSETS AND DO ALL THIS
KIND OF STUFF.
IT'S ADDED COST IT COSTS MORE
MONEY IT'S CUMBERSOME AND YOU'RE
DOING IT FOR A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMPARED TO CAL FRESH OR
CAL.
YEAH -- MEDI CAL.
SO THE MEDICARE POPULATION IS
WAY OVER WHAT TWELVE THIRTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE THE HELL FRESH
WATER WITHOUT.
FIVE MILLION. FOUR MILLION AND
AND AND CAL WORKS.
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA? THREE QUARTERS OF A
MILLION.
SO SO FOR ME TO MAKES THIS
PROGRAM CONSISTENT [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
EVERYTHING.
AND HAVE A SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION PROCESS IS A THE
GOAL TO SAVE MONEY AND WOULD
SAVE MONEY SO I THINK THE BILL
WOULD ACTUALLY.
SAVE MONEY ON THE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSING OF OF
THIS PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
OTHER PROGRAMS YOU WOULD HAVE.
TO BE ABLE TO GET A LOT MORE
WORK DONE.
WITHOUT HAVING.
TO GO THROUGH IS CUMBERSOME
ASSET.
TEST THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU CENTER ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS.
IT'S NOT WHICH I CALL CENTER IN.
THIS REQUEST RIVALS.
OKAY THIS IS -- GONNA BE GOING
WHERE NEXT. TO A CORPORATION TO
A MOTION.
THE BILL SENATOR PAN AS MOVE THE
BILL TO APPROPRIATIONS IF YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HURTADO STONE NO STONE NO.
BELL BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN HI CAN AYE
WIENER.
WIENER HI. FOUR ONE FOUR ONE WAY
TO KEEP THE ROLE OF THE SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
SENATOR PAN SP.
FOUR TO ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO OVER NINE
MILLION CHILDREN AND WHILE CHILD
WELFARE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE THEM ON
THE WORST OUTCOME FOR CHILDREN
HEALTH EDUCATION JUVENILE DOES
JUSTICE. FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
RANKS FORTY FIRST IN FOR PUPILS --
FOR STUDENTS SPENDING WE RANK
FORTY THIRD FOR THE RATE OF
YOUNG KIDS RECEIVING THE
VOLATILE SCREENINGS.
ALTHOUGH HELPED CHANGE THAT AND
HALF OF KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
FOSTER CARE HAVE ENTERED FOR
MORE CHILDHOOD ADVERSE EXPENSE
OURS AMAZED AS ACES WHICH ARE
MORE LIKELY TO LEAD TO CHRONIC
DISEASE IN ADULTHOOD -- WE DO
HAVE MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES THAT AIM TO ALLEVIATE
THESE CHALLENGES AND YET --
WE'VE HAD SOME CHALLENGES IN
TRYING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE THESE
MEASURES OF CHILD WELL BEING.
A AYE CHILDREN'S CABINET MADE OF
QUE AGENCY LEADERS CAN HELP
MOBILIZE EFFORTS AND RESOURCES
AROUND STATE PRIORITIES FOR
CHILDREN IMPROVE EFFICIENCY AND
STATE DELIVERY ACROSS THE STATE
AND LOCAL DEPARTMENTS.
AS BEFORE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CHILDREN'S CABINET
TO DEVELOP A SHARED VISION AMONG
THE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND
OR TO IMPROVE CHILD AND FAMILY
OUT COMES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION CONSIDERS CHILDREN'S
CABINETS A EST PRACTICE AS SET
FORTH GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR
ESTABLISHING A CHILDREN'S
CABINET.
I LOOK FORWARD TO USE THAT BY
USING THESE GUIDING PRINCIPLES A
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
REFINE THE CHILLS CABINET
SPECIFIC GOALS TIMELINE TO
MEMBERSHIP IN ORDER.
TO ENSURE ITS SUCCESS AND
CERTAINLY AS MENTIONED DEAL AS A
CHAIR OF A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
THINK WE SEE ALL THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND WE NOTICED
SOMETIMES THE SILOS THEY TEND TO
RESIDE IN.
AND SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
AGAIN TRY TO BRIDGE THOSE SILOS
AND HAVE AN ORGANIZATION WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT WILL DO
HIGH LEVEL BUT COORDINATED
EFFORTS TO HELP IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENNED UP WE
HAVE INDEED -- TESTIMONY IN
FAVOR PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN CANYON
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
IF NOT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB FOUR TWENTY ONE PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SIGNAL COME BACK TO OUR FELLOW
SENATORS -- A MOTION -- QUESTION.
SENATOR JACKSON YEAH I I THINK
THIS IS A FASCINATING DEA -- IN
AND APPRECIATE THE OUR RESIDENTS --
PEDIATRICIAN.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE HERE
OF HAVING A SOME KIND OF
RECOGNITION OF SORT OF THE
CONTINUUM WHICH IS WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE YOU'RE TRYING
TO CREATE HERE -- I'M WONDERING
HOW COULD YOU KIND OF SURE HOW
YOU ENVISION THIS HAPPENING.
WELL I I THINK THAT -- WE WE DO
HAVE A I THINK THE IDEA IS IS
THAT -- WE HAVE THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP AND THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES THAT TOUCH CHILDREN.
AND AND THE IDEA IS IS THAT --
THAT.
THAT HOPEFULLY THEY CAN -- THEY
WOULD BE SORT OF THE PLACE WHERE
AT THE ADMINISTRATION CAN THINK
STRATEGICALLY AND THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN CROSS THOSE DIFFERENT
SILAS BECAUSE I THINK THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT SALAS SO.
I USED TO CHAIR SELECT ME
ACCIONES SPECIAL NEEDS AND THAT
WE HAVE.
EDGE SPECIAL ED WAS AN EDUCATION
RIGHT AND THEN WE HAD
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WAS A AND
AND AND AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
THEN YOU HAVE -- THAT IT YOU
KNOW THE HEALTH AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND AND AND AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT YOU HAVE THINGS FRAGMENT
ACROSS DIFFERENT -- AGENCIES IN
FACT ACTUALLY INTERESTING ENOUGH
WE HAD ONE OF OUR FIRST HEARINGS --
I WAS OUT SAY THAT MOST OF THE
TIME THEY HAD ME TALK TO EACH
OTHER AS A FIRST TIME THEY HEARD
FROM EACH OTHER WHAT EACH OF
THEM WERE DOING FOR PHYSICALLY
CHILDREN'S SPECIAL NEEDS SELF
BUT GIVEN THAT BUT FIRST SELECT
COMMITTEE WAS ABOUT.
I THINK WE NEED THIS -- LARGER
OWES A WE HAVE THINGS LIKE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL OTHER
TYPES OF BODIES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT BEEN PLACE
TO LOOK STRATEGICALLY ACROSS --
THINGS AND I THINK WE NEED ONE
FOR CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY AND
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT -- WITH THIS --
BILL WELL WELL -- PROMPT THAT
KIND OF DISCUSSION AND ALSO LEAD
TO EVENTUALLY I AN ORGANIZATION
WE WILL WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL ON ON
THIS SO -- AS THE BILL WAS
FORCED.
IF I MAY ONE OTHER QUESTION IS I
DON'T RECALL SEEING ARE THERE
ANY OTHER STATES THAT HAVE DONE
ANYTHING SIMILAR TO THIS.
ARE THERE ARE OTHER STATES THAT
THE HAVE A CHILDREN'S CABINETS
AND AS I MENTIONED IT'S
CONSIDERED A BEST PRACTICE BY
THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION -- SO THAT IT SO
THERE AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE
OTHER OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
JONES CABINETS CENTER IS THIS
MODELED AFTER THE MORE WOULD
THIS BE UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA.
WELL I THINK WE ARE LOOKING AT
USING THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION OF BEST PRACTICES AS
A GUIDANCE TO THE DEVELOPMENT
THIS OF COURSE AGAIN WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE CURRENT
MINISTRATION WHICH WHO HAS
EXPRESSED A TREMENDOUS INTEREST
IN CHILDREN.
AND IN SHAPING IT IN A WAY THAT
BEST MEETS THE NEEDS OF OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S AMAZING WHAT
HAPPENS FROM THE GOVERNOR HAS
FOR LITTLE CHILDREN TEN YEARS OF
AGE AND UNDER.
THE KIND OF CAN'T HELP
THEMSELVES CAN THEY YES.
WELL THAT'S A GOOD THING THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER ON LIKE
YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH MOTION BY SENATOR
JACKSON IN THE FOR QUESTIONS.
IF NOT THOUGH WE'RE GONNA CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS GOING TO WEAR.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OKAY.
THIS CALL A HELLO STONE BY STONE
AYE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN HI CAN I WIENER
RIGHT WIENER AYE.
AS FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
IN ON THE ROLE OF AN CENTER AND
THANK YOU FOR GRADUATION.
AND THE OTHER BILL HAS A SECOND
BILL.
VIOLENT TEMPER SB FIVE ONE TWO
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHARE OF OYSTER MEMBERS -- FOR
THE SAKE PERCENT SB FIVE TWELVE
AND I THINK OF WHICH TAKES THE
FIRST CRITICAL STEP TO CREATING
A NEW LONG TERM.
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS OUR L. TSS
BENEFIT FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION
THIS NEW BENEFIT IS URGENT
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER OLDER ADULTS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL DISABILITIES CURRENTLY
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS POPULATION WILL GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE.
UNFORTUNATELY MEDI CAL.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIANS
LACK ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE L. D.
S. A SERVICES.
LONG TERM SUPPORT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
COVERED BY MEDICARE AND MISS
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD TO
PURCHASE PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE.
PAYING OUT OF POCKET FOR LTE
ASSESSES HOW EXPENSIVE INCREASE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL SOCIAL
BURDEN FOR FAMILIES.
ALTERNATIVELY AND FORTUNATELY
THIS IS PERHAPS THE MOST
FREQUENT -- SCENARIO
CALIFORNIANS MUST SPEND DOWN
THROUGH THEIR LIFE SAVINGS TO
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE.
AND TO OFFER THIS IS THE PRIMARY
MEANS BY WHICH OLDER ADULTS AND
INDIVIDUALS DISABILITIES CURLY
RECEIVE ACCESS TO PAY LONG TERM
SUPPORT SIR AND SERVICES.
MEDI CAL IS A CRITICAL SAFETY
NET BUT THE SYSTEM IS
OVERBURDENED.
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD HAVE TO
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES A SPEND
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AND OUR
CHILDREN'S INHERITANCE OR FORGO
WORKING AND GENERATING EARNED
INCOME.
IN ORDER TO ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES THEY NEED TO LIVE
INDEPENDENT HIGH QUALITY OF LIFE.
THIS LEGISLATION IS CREATING A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF
A LONG TERM.
OF A LONG TERM SERVICE OF THE
SUPPORTS BENEFIT TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE TWELVE
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE
MODELED AFTER DE CAL SEAVER
SECURE CHOICE PROGRAM. FOR WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S REDESIGNED AND
FINANCE THIS NEW BENEFIT INDEED
THE LEGISLATION SPONSORED BY
CALIFORNIA AGING AND DISABILITY
ALLIANCE WHICH REPRESENTS TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF L. D. S. A
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD NOW TO
PUT THESE CRITICAL PIECES IN
PLACE SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
MOVING FORWARD WITH BENEFIT
FINANCING DECIDE.
SO -- THAT I'D HAVE -- MANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE AND I
APPRECIATE THEIR PATIENCE.
IN WAITING AT TO THE VERY END OF
THE HEARING AND I HOPE THAT HAVE
YOUR AYE VOTES NOT WHEN WE
CONCLUDE THANK YOU.
YOU SENATOR WE WELCOME YOUR
WITNESSES.
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE AND IN A WHILE
THE HEART WELL WITH A OR P.
CALIFORNIA A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGING AND DISABILITY
ALLIANCE OF COURSE.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE OUR
SPEAKER TODAY CAN RADO CAMERINO
HE'S IN A OR P. VOLUNTEER.
AND CARE GIVER COMING HERE ALL
THE WAY FROM FAIRFIELD AND ALSO
RETIRED AIR FORCE VETERANS.
COMMANDERS SERVER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT.
AS MENTIONED MY NAME'S COLORADO
CAMERI NOW -- I VOLUNTEER WITH
A. R. P..
AND I HAVE BEEN A CARE GIVER FOR
MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS.
AS MENTIONED A. R. P. IS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA AGING
AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE.
WHICH IS SPONSORINGTHIS SB.
FIVE ONE TWO AND IT IS A HIGH
PRIORITY BILL FOR A A RP BECAUSE
L. TSS COST -- MORE THAN MOST
CALIFORNIA'S CAN AFFORD.
A A RP RESEARCH FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SHOW THAT THE AVERAGE
ANNUAL COST OF NURSING HOME CARE
IS ABOUT DOUBLE.
THE MEDIAN INCOME FOR OLDER
HOUSEHOLDS.
BOB ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND
PER YEAR FOR A PRIVATE ROOM AND
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR
SHARED FROM.
HIRING A HOME CARE PROVIDER AND
THIS IS SOMETHING I'M NOT
FAMILIAR ABOUT BECAUSE OF MY MOM --
COSTS FOR THIRTY HOURS A WEEK
BECAUSE BETWEEN230-002-40000
DOLLARS A YEAR DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE SPENDING ON
LOCATION.
MOST FAMILY SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
THIS IN FACT ONLY 5% OF
CALIFORNIANS. 5%.
WERE ABLE -- TO PURCHASE LONG
TERM CARE POLICY.
SB FIVE ONE TWO IS ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME PERSONALLY.
I LOST BOTH MY FATHER AND MY
MOTHER IN LAW LAST YEAR.
AND OUR FAMILY SPENT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OUT OF
POCKET.
THE TAKE CARE OF OUR PARENTS.
WE ALSO HAVE A HAD TO TAKE TIME
OFF FROM WORK.
LEAVE OUR FAMILIES BEHIND.
AND HAVE HAD TO NAVIGATE THE
FRAGMENTED -- THIS JOINT THAT
PATCHWORK OF SERVICES THAT COULD
BE AVAILABLE TO OUR LOVED ONES.
MY WIFE AND HER SIX SIBLINGS
THANK GOD FOR BIG FILIPINO
FAMILIES.
TOOK TURNS TAKING CARE OF MY
MOTHER IN LAW DYING OF
PANCREATIC CANCER.
A SISTER IN LAW FLEW FROM WEST
VIRGINIA THE TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
STATE WEEKS AT A TIME.
AND TOOK CARE OF MY MOTHER IN
LAW.
ANOTHER SISTER IN LAW.
FLOWING FROM NORTH CAROLINA DID
THE SAME THING.
AND MY WIFE AND I DROVE AND
SOMETIMES WE FLEW FROM FAIRFIELD
THE TORRANCE.
THE OTHER FOUR SIBLINGS WHO LIVE
IN THE SOUTHERN CAL ALSO I HAD
TO SPEND TIME OFF FROM WORK AS
THEY TOOK.
THEIR TURNS SITTING BY MY MOTHER
IN LAW'S BEDSIDE.
ADMINISTERING TO HER NEEDS.
MY FATHER WAS NINETY ONE YEARS
OLD WHEN HE PASSED AWAY LAST
YEAR.
HE OFTEN HAD MULTIPLE DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS A WEEKLY AND NOW WE
HAVE TO TRANSPORT HIM -- WHILE
HE TOOK PARA TRANSIT THEM UP AND
HAYWARD BUT HE HE NEEDED TO GO
TO THE DIALYSIS -- CLINICS.
EXCUSE ME OF THREE TIMES A WEEK.
JUST ONE HOUR APPOINTMENT FOR
HIM THANK YOU JUST ONE HOUR
APPOINTMENT FOR AND IS A WHOLE
DAY AFFAIR FOR ME.
BECAUSE I HAD TO DRIVE FROM
FAIRFIELD PICK HIM UP OKAY WORD
AND THEN.
TOOK HIM TO THE DOCTORS IN THE
BAY AREA.
AND MY MOTHER MY LONE SRVIVING
PARENT LIVES IN ALAMEDA AND SHE
WILL TURN EIGHTY SIX NEXT MONTH
[inaudible]
EVA MAE. FOR A LONG TIME SHE
STRUGGLED BECAUSE HER MONTHLY
PENSION WAS TWENTY DOLLARS ABOVE
THE THRESHOLD FOR HER TO QUALIFY
FOR MEDICARE.
AND IT TOOK A LOT OF TIME AND
RESEARCH AND NETWORKING.
THE HER A TO SECURE HER IN HOME
SERVICES.
FELL BECAUSE OF THESE
EXPERIENCES I BECAME AN A. R. P..
A. R. P. VOLUNTEER.
I HOPE FOR A TIME WHEN FAMILIES
WILL HAVE BETTER OPTIONS.
SO THAT THEY WON'T HAVE TO SPEND
AS MUCH OUT OF POCKET THE TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES.
AS MY FAMILIES THEY DID.
AND THEY WON'T HAVE TO TAKE THAT
TAKE TIME OFF FROM WORK BILL
DEALING WITH LOST WAGES.
AND FUTURE SOCIAL SECURITY
INCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR SERVICE IN YOUR
TESTIMONY.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S
KRISTINA MILLS AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB FIVE ONE TWO AND
DAD MEMBER AT THE CALIFORNIA
AGING AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE.
WHICH I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
IS VERY UNIQUELY POSITIONED IN
WORKING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ACROSS THE LIFESPAN
AS WELL AS THE AGENT COMMUNITY
TO PUSH SB FIVE ONE TWO FORWARD.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY AS A MEMBER
OF THE SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY WHO
LIKE ME WAS BORN WITH A
DISABILITY AND HAS HAD TO MAKE
SOME DIFFICULT CHOICES BECAUSE
OF L. TSS SERVICES THAT ARE AND
ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING SENATORS -- AS
MENTIONED MY NAME IS KIM LATER
UP I AM THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD
AND I LIVE WITH A DISABILITY.
I WAS BORN WITHOUT ARMS AND LEGS.
I ALSO AM BORN AND RAISED HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M A
REGISTERED VOTER.
I HAVE ALSO BEEN RECEIVING LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES SINCE
I WAS SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD.
I'D LIKE TO THANKYOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE BILL.
FIVE TWELVE EVER SINCE I WAS
YOUNG I WAS ALWAYS TOLD THAT
WORKING FULL TIME AND KEEPING MY
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
IS JUST NOT REALISTIC.
HEARING THIS CREATED THE DESIRE
WITHIN ME TO WANT TO WORK FULL
TIME EVEN MORE.
I WANTED TO COME HOME AT NIGHT
pMY PART IN CONTRIBUTING AND
GIVING BACK TO MY COMMUNITIES.
BUT THEN I ALSO DID MY PART AS A
TAX PAYING AMERICAN TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COUNTRY.
IF YOU YEARS AGO MY DREAM BECAME
A REALITY WHEN I WAS OFFERED MY
VERY FIRST INTERNSHIP.
SHORTLY AFTER MY INTERNSHIP
TURNED INTO A PART TIME JOB.
AND EVENTUALLY I WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK FULL TIME.
IT WAS A DIFFICULT DECISION FOR
ME TO MAKE HOWEVER BECAUSE I
KNEW THERE WAS ONLY SO MUCH
INCOME I COULD EARN.
IN ORDER TO KEEP MY LONG TERM
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
NONETHELESS I OPTIMISTICALLY
MOVED FORWARD ALWAYS MAKING SURE
THAT I NEVER WENT OVER THE
INCOME THRESHOLD.
AS TO NOT JEOPARDIZE MY LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
BUT IN DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN MY FATHER PASSED AWAY.
AND I BEGAN RECEIVING HIS SOME
OF HIS BENEFITS.
THIS MEANT THERE WAS NO WAY I
COULD KEEP MY EARNED INCOME.
AND MY LONG TERM SUPPORT AND
SERVICES.
IN THAT MOMENT I WAS FACED WITH
A CHOICE. TO EITHER LOSE MY
PERSONAL SERVICES WHICH CONSISTS
OF MY HEALTH CARE AND MY
PERSONAL CARE ATTENDANTS.
THAT ENABLES ME TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
OR I WOULD HAVE TO QUIT MY JOB.
A JOB THAT I WORKED SO HARD.
FOR A JOB THAT I WAS GROWING MY
SKILLS IN.
AND WHERE I WAS BUILDING MY
COMMUNITY AND NETWORK THROUGH.
I FELT HEARTBROKEN THAT I WAS
FORCED TO GIVE UP EVERYTHING
THAT I WORKED SO HARD.
FOR AND I WAS ALSO DISAPPOINTED
TO KNOW THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
KEPT ON GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE.
AND THAT I WAS GENERALLY JUST
TAKING A STEP BACKWARDS IN MY
LIFE.
BUT THERE'D BE NO WAY I COULD
AFFORD OUT OF POCKET COSTS WITH
HEALTH CARE ON MY EARNED INCOME
ALONE.
SO I DID QUIT MY JOB.
JUST TO MAINTAIN LIVING IN MY
HOME AND LIVING INDEPENDENTLY.
I AM NOT ALONE THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WERE FORCED TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS EVERY DAY.
WHETHER WE CHOOSE TO PURSUE JOBS
CAREERS AND EARN INCOME.
OR KEEP THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT ALLOWS US TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN OUR OWN HOMES.
THIS DECISION IS NOT FAIR AND
IT'S ALWAYS PLACED ON PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
TWELVE THERE WILL BE MORE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF.
WHO SO THAT THEY WILL NOT BE
FORCED INTO THESE UNFAIR
SITUATIONS?
WITH SB FIVE TWELVE THERE WILL
BE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
BE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO PURSUE A
CAREER WITHOUT RISKING OUR
SERVICES.
SERVICES THAT WE NEED IN ORDER%
TO LIVE THE LIFE WE DESERVE. TO
LIVE SAFELY AND INDEPENDENTLY
AND OUR OWN HOMES AND WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WE
APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE WHEN TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING SIX BED WHICH IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX BEDS
ARE FEWER RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THE ONLY THING WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE.
IS A MORE ROBUST REPRESENTATION
OF PROVIDERS ON THE BOARD IF
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR JUST FUNDING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SUCH AT
HAMPTON LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA
A PROUD MEMBER OF CALVARY AGING
DISABILITY ALLIANCE AND TRUNKS
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS LIKE JOHNSON
HEREBY OFF THE CHARGER FILMA
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TURN MEMBERS FROM OWN CASA
BLANKA REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
WINES RETURN MEREKA ENDS WITH
OVER ONE MILLION MEMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PETER HAS A WITH CAL PACE
REPRESENTING THE PROGRAMS OF
CALL ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY CARING FOR A OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND FRAIL SENIORS AND OLDER
ADULTS IN THE COMMUNITY -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIAN A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY BLOMBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES
REPRESENTING NINE HUNDRED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
FOUR HUNDRED INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT A SERVICE?
MY NUMBER IS JOAQUIN.
THEY'VE GONE THAT'LL THERE MY
THERE ARE IMPROVE AT ALL.
THEY ACTUALLY SAYS SAYING.
THE UP ALL YOUR A UNION THOSE
ALSO. FOR BORDERS THROWS FEEL OF
ANIMALS BUT SAUNAS GONE THE
SEVENTY THAT IS.
THEY'VE BEEN SET MOST PROPERLY
THAT IN EACH WITH ADDRESS.
HELLO MY NAME IS WORKING I AM
FROM MADERA COUNTY I AM AN AYE
HSS PROVIDER AND YOU DO W.
MEMBER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
FIVE TWELVE BECAUSE SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES SHOULD
BE THE TOP PRIORITY NOT AN
AFTERTHOUGHT BECAUSE HE'S
WORKING.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LINDSAY
MY HONG I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
TWO ORGANIZATIONS.
HAND IN HAND THE DOMESTIC
EMPLOYERS NETWORK AND THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE TWELVE WE OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO BOTH RECEIVE
L. TSS AND PEOPLE WHO PROVIDED.
AND WE SEE THIS AS BEING A
REALLY IMPORTANT STEP TO
CREATING THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SENT THE SYSTEM THAT WE
NEED -- I WANT TO SHARE TO MORE
EXAMPLES WE HEARD REALLY --
POWERFUL EXAMPLES RIGHT NOW AND
I MET WITH TWO PEOPLE JUST LAST
WEEK WHO COULD REALLY BENEFIT
FROM -- THIS BILL AND FROM WHAT
IT COULD CREATE ONE IS A A
FAMILY CAREGIVER LIVING AND IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY WHO SUPPORTING
HER FATHER SHE BECAME HER
FAMILY'S.
AT HER FATHER'S FAMILY CARE
GIVER WHO WE CAN ASK WHO GOT
ALZHEIMER'S AFTER HAVING.
BEEN A CITY ARCHITECT AND
WORKING FOR TWO DIFFERENT CITIES
AND BAY AREA HE LIVES OFF A
PENSION BUT HI THIS IS GONNA BE
THE FIRST MONTH OF THEIR FAMILY
CAN'T AFFORD ALL THE COSTS --
FOR HIS HOME CARE AS WELL AS AS
HIS RENDON IS HOUSING FAMILY I
MET A WOMAN WHO HAS LIVED WITH
MS FOR THE LAST FORTY YEARS YOU
RAN THE SENIOR CENTER FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ALSO HAS A
PENSION.
DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR MEDICAID
SIMILAR TO THE THE GENTLEMAN I
WAS JUST SPEAKING OF AND BARELY
SQUEAKS BY SHE'S Là LITERALLY
YOU KNOW. ONE I'M PENSION PAY
AWAY FROM LOSING OUR HOUSING IF
ANYTHING WERE TO CHANGE AND HER
EXPENSES.
THIS IS A A REAL NEAT THANK YOU.
WE JUST GIVE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION MISS
CARE BY STIR.
AND MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF LCI YOU CALIFORNIAN ARE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IN STRONG SUPPORT A MEMBER OF
THE COALITION THANK YOU.
MORNING CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON
WITH UT W. REPRESENTING I JUST
US WORKERS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
COALITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSURE CONFIDE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA STATE INDEPENDENT
LIVING COUNCIL.
AND ALL ALSO PERSONALLY I'M A
PART TIME CARE GIVER FOR MY
NINETY YEAR OLD MOTHER WHO LIVES
WITH ME.
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING I'M SUSAN TO MORRIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AND A
ROOM AND A MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE.
THE AVERAGE LIFETIME COST OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS JUST
UNDER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WE SUPPORT SB
FIVE TWELVE THANK YOU.
CAROL SUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE ALLIANCE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN HEYMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
THEY SERVICES AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ALAIN QUEEN MERCED COUNTY I
CHAVEZ PROVIDER YOU W. MEMBER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE TWELVE
BECAUSE IT IS A PROACTIVE
FORWARD PROCESS. TO APPROACHING
A HUGELY GROWING HUMAN CONCERN
THANK YOU.
HELLO PARALYSIS HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS STANISLAUS COUNTY.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE NO ONE SHOULD.
HAVE BECOME POOR JUST TO AFFORD
CARE.
MY DAUGHTER LEFT A VERY GOOD
PAYING JOBS. TO CARE FOR MY
GRANDSON THIS IS STAINED ATV I
WHICH LEFT HIM.
WHEELCHAIR BOUND AND NONVERBAL.
THEY OWN THEIR HOME AND THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE.
TO SELL THEIR HOME JUST TO BE
ABLE TO GET SOMETHING HAPPENED
TO THEM.
I THINK YOU ARE AND THERE NEARLY
FIFTY HIMSELF WITH THE NAY MANY
CARE.
I MANY.
THANK YOU ANY ANYMORE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
IF NOT PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITION FORWARD.
AND ABOUT TO OCCUR.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE BILL.
RIGHT AT THE AGAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AS QUICKLY AS WHEN
I VOTE [inaudible]
SO.
HE PASSED THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO OF FOR DO
PASSED THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
THE CARD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RETIRA I'D HER TITLE I STONE
STONE I DON'T.
KNOW I JACKSON.
JACKSON I CAN I CAN I WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER HI.
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS SIX ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
ADAMS TO SEVEN HIGH ENERGY.
ITEMS TO ITEM SEVEN AND IN ITEM
A YEAH YOU DO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL RIGHT.
SO.
THE FIRST ONE IS ITEM TO SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT WIENER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR -- CHAIRS NOT VOTED THEM
VOTE IS.
FOR ONE HER TITLE.
HER TITLE I IT'S FIVE ONE INTO
THE THE BILL IS FIVE ONE AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
I AM ITEM THAT THE NEXT ONE IS --
SB THREE NINETY EIGHT ZERO ZERO
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIR IS
THAT THERE ARE CARE VOTES I AM
THE JACKSON [inaudible]
JACKSON I AT BOTTOM. SIX SIX
ZERO THE BILL IS.
SIX ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT.
IN THE ITEM EIGHT AS BEFORE.
TWENTY ONE PAN THE MOTION IS THE
PASTOR GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE -- THE VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO CHAIR IS NOT VOTED HURTADO
I HURTADO I SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
SIX ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND THIS ENDS UP OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TODAY FOR THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE